bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien aujourd'hui une vidéo un peu
inhabituelle parce que je vais vous
faire le top 10 de mes lectures de 2022
alors oui normalement la vidéo aurait dû
sortir en fin d'année dernière mais bon
j'ai déménagé puis bon j'ai eu plein
d'imprévus et puis après tout pourquoi
ne pas faire le bilan de l'année en
plein mois de juin qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire en plus c'est bientôt l'été donc
ça vous donnera peut-être des idées de
lecture pour les vacances le principe
très simple il se trouve que je lis pas
mal de choses tout au long de l'année et
que en général j'en parle ni en vidéo ni
sur les réseaux et donc c'est simplement
l'occasion de revenir sur les 10 livres
que j'ai préféré en 2022 évidemment
c'est un classement 100% subjectif et il
dépend uniquement de ce que j'ai lu dans
l'année sans que ce soit forcément
d'ailleurs des livres qui sont parus
cette année-là même si en général c'est
quand même des livres plutôt récents
donc évidemment je ne vais parler ici
que des livres que j'ai lu mais
n'hésitez pas à me mettre dans les
commentaires les livres qui vous ont le
plus marqué l'année dernière on va se
faire la mégaliste ultime de lecture de
vacances bon alors j'ai classé les
livres de la dixième à la première place
pour créer un peu de suspense mais si
vous vous en foutez de vous faire
spoiler vous pouvez retrouver les
références en description et surtout il
y a les timecodes si vous voulez passer
à un livre en particulier si c'est bon
pour vous on y va
[Musique]
alors avant de commencer directement le
top 10 je vais prendre une petite minute
pour vous parler de trois livres que
j'ai quand même trouvé à s'intéressant
mais qui ne se sont quand même pas
frayés un chemin jusqu'au top
premièrement je vais donc vous dire deux
mots de homo deus une brève histoire de
l'avenir de l'historien israélien Yuval
Noah hahari sortie en anglais en 2016
alors vous connaissez sûrement Harari
notamment pour son livre sapiens ce qui
a été un succès international et qui
prenait le pari de raconter toute
l'histoire de l'humanité de la
préhistoire à nos jours ce livre donc se
présente un peu comme la suite et il
essaye de réfléchir à l'avenir de
l'humanité alors j'étais un peu
sceptique au début mais le livre
finalement est assez sympa et surtout on
retrouve la façon d'écrire de Harari qui
est une masterclass de vulgarisation en
destination du grand public il y a une
vidéo de la chaîne marketing Mania qui
analyse un peu le style de Harari et il
montre que bon ok il fait pas mal
d'approximations ce qui est inévitable
qu'on en prend une échelle de temps
comme celle-ci mais que son génie réside
plutôt dans son storytelling et cette
façon qu'il a de nous raconter
l'histoire de l'humanité comme un polar
dans ce tome donc il essaye de réfléchir
au futur de l'humanité est-ce que ça va
changer à notre rapport au monde en ça
c'est un livre très différent de sapiens
parce qu'il est avant tout prospectif il
pose des questions sur l'évolution des
sociétés humaines par exemple en
imaginant que les progrès de la médecine
arrivent à nous faire vivre jusqu'à 150
ans est-ce qu'on aura toujours une
vision du mariage comme de venturer
toute la vie si tenter que c'est déjà la
vision qu'on a aujourd'hui est-ce que le
fait d'élever nos enfants entre nos 30
et nos 50 ans à peu près ça ne deviendra
pas finalement une petite partie un peu
anecdotique dans toutes les tendues de
notre vie comment gérera la question du
travail et des retraites bon c'est juste
un exemple parmi d'autres mais il pose
un certain nombre de questions et fait
des expériences de pensée qui sont assez
intéressantes en observant la réalité
actuelle et en gros en poussant les
potards un peu plus loin pour regarder
ce qui pourrait advenir du coup ça fait
du livre un objet assez hybride parce
que il est pas mal sourcé dans
l'histoire et dans le présent pour
saisir un petit peu les tendances et les
questionnements souvent très actuels
mais une forte dimension prospective où
il va essayer de réfléchir au rapport
entre l'humanité avec le vivant le
cybernétique comment le développement
technologique va changer notre rapport
au monde un des points qu'il développe
pas mal et qui m'avait déjà plus dans le
premier tome c'est notamment l'analyse
qu'il fait des fictions et comment les
fictions sont essentielles parce
qu'elles permettent la coopération entre
les hommes alors sur le terme fiction il
parle bien sûr des religions mais aussi
de l'éthique des valeurs et plus
précisément de l'humanisme qui est selon
lui devenu la nouvelle religion du 20e
siècle alors en soi c'est pas une thèse
nouvelle du tout c'est déjà ce que
disait Durkheim à la fin du 19e siècle
dans un article qui s'appelle
l'individualisme et les intellectuels où
il écrivait que l'individualisme est
devenu une religion dont l'homme est à
la fois le fidèle et le Dieu mais là où
Harry innove c'est qu'il prédit
justement la chute de cette religion
humaniste dans un 21e siècle où les
machines vont devenir supérieures aux
hommes en tout point donc évidemment je
ne vous conseille pas vraiment ce livre
si ce que vous cherchez c'est avant tout
une rigueur scientifique indiscutable
assez réception plusieurs critiques lui
ont notamment reproché de céder à la
mode des ouvrages apocalyptiques sur le
futur de l'humanité mais si vous
cherchez un livre admirablement bien
écrit et facile à lire qui pose des
questions à ces stimulantes sur l'avenir
de l'humanité je ne vois aucune raison
de ne pas vous le conseiller j'ai pas
encore lu le livre qu'il a sorti après
là les 21 leçons pour le 21e siècle mais
je vais peut-être me laisser tenter et
dans ce cas peut-être qu'on en reparlera
l'année prochaine
livre suivant alors pour les livres qui
suivent je vais aborder un sujet un peu
particulier et oui cette année j'ai lu
deux livres de Gérald Bronner et il se
trouve que j'ai un problème avec
géraldrunner j'arrive pas à m'en faire
un avis définitif donc bon pour vous
présenter rapidement le bonhomme il est
professeur de sociologie à l'Université
de Paris membre de l'Académie de
médecine il travaille sur la rationalité
et c'est notamment en tenant de
l'individualisme méthodologique de
Raymond Boudon en 2017 il a publié avec
Étienne Guéant un pamphlet qui a fait un
peu de bruit le danger sociologique donc
Karim de la chaîne politique one avait
d'ailleurs fait une capsule à l'époque
et bon quand je dis que le livre a fait
du bruit c'est surtout vrai dans la
sphère médiatique finalement assez peu
dans la sphère scientifique parce qu'en
fait il utilise la technique de l'homme
de paille quand il essaye de
décrédibiliser ce qu'il appelle les
sociologues déterministes au premier
rang desquels il place évidemment
Bourdieu et ses héritiers et justement
j'en arrive au point un peu particulier
de bon que d'un côté il est bien
installé dans le champ académique et
médiatique il est prof à l'Université de
Paris il a même été missionné l'an
dernier par Emmanuel Macron pour faire
une Commission visant à réfléchir à la
régulation des fausses informations mais
dans notre côté il reste quand même
assez isolé sur le plan scientifique
quand on connaît un petit peu le chant
de la recherche en sociologie en fait
greneur c'est surtout une figure très
médiatique dès qu'il sort en bouquin il
est reçu partout à la télé à la radio il
a par exemple son rond de serviette chez
quotidien ou dans la matinale de France
Culture donc en ça il a une couverture
bien supérieure à la majorité des
sociologues mais quand on regarde ces
publications justement on s’aperçoit
qu'il sort pas mal de petits essais de
petits livres qui ont une ambition
scientifique finalement assez modeste et
d'ailleurs où il recycle un petit peu
souvent les mêmes idées
mais bon pourquoi je vous tenais à vous
en parler mais c'est parce que j'ai des
sentiments mitigés à son sujet le fait
que même s'il m'énerve à plein de
niveaux et que je suis rarement d'accord
avec lui
et ben je l'aime bien quand même quand
il passe à la radio je suis content de
l'écouter même si c'est pour parler de
sa vie personnelle et de comment lui il
a super bien vécu son ascension sociale
pas comme tout s'est transfuge fragiles
qui mettent en avant le dolorisme dans
leur récit il y a des sillons narratifs
qui peuvent nous égarer et un de ces si
on narratif que j'étudie c'est le
dolorisme c'est-à-dire effectivement
l'exaltation de la douleur pour se
raconter soi-même qui est très tangible
là dans le discours de d'Édouard Louis
je caricature évidemment mais c'est
justement là mon propos c'est que de la
même façon que Brunner il a tendance à
caricaturer les autres bah ça peut être
facile de le caricaturer lui et en
général quand on l'écoute ou qu'on le
lit il a une vision souvent plus
intéressante que cette caricature et
c'est en fait assez rare que je m'ennuie
quand je l'écoute passer dans un média
mais bon comme je vous disais j'ai
encore du mal à me faire un avis
définitif sur Gérald Browner il faudra
probablement que j'y réfléchisse
davantage et en attendant si ça vous
intéresse je vous conseille un billet de
blog de Tranxen qu'il avait consacré à
Gérald Brunner et qui donne pas mal
d'éléments de Ré sur le sujet mais trêve
de présentation j'ai donc lu son livre
apocalypse cognitive sortie en 2021 opus
ou presse universitaire de France et
pour vous présenter rapidement l'ouvrage
il traite de ces sujets de prédilection
à savoir le cerveau les biais cognitifs
les moyens de communication moderne son
concept central c'est celui d'une
dérégulation du marché de l'information
à l'aire d'Internet et des difficultés
de notre cerveau à y faire face alors le
livre est assez intéressant il commence
par une petite histoire de l'humanité et
de la façon dont notre cerveau a été
façonné par notre histoire évolutive
l'idée c'est que notre cerveau actuel
est globalement le même que celui des
chasseurs cueilleurs d'il y a plusieurs
milliers d'années mais que comme nous
vivons dans un milieu complètement
différent nous sommes globalement
inadaptés pour faire face aux moyens
modernes de communication et d'échanges
plus précisément et souligne que nous
avons de nombreux biais cognitifs qui
ont pu être très utile à une époque de
notre révolution ça il y a pas il y a
pas de doute mais qui sont plutôt
aujourd'hui un frein à la pensée
rationnelle dans ce contexte le livre
soutient trois tests principales
première que nous avons aujourd'hui ce
qu'il appelle un temps de cerveau
disponible très élevé et qu'une grande
partie de ce temps est affectée aux
usages d'Internet
deuxièmement l'idée que internet est un
marché cognitif dérégulé et notamment
que les mécanismes de ce marché
permettent de révéler de façon
transparente ou presque les préférences
humaines en regardant par exemple le
type de site web qui sont les plus
visités et globalement ça donne pas une
belle image de nous parce que on est
beaucoup plus attiré par les contenus à
caractère sexuel que par les œuvres de
la philosophie allemande pour ne prendre
qu'un exemple et enfin sa troisième
thèse c'est que nos comportements en
ligne ne sont pas spécifiques à notre
époque mais correspondent à une sorte de
nature humaine qui serait le fruit de
notre parcours évolutif en gros on a
tous le même type de cerveau cette
troisième thèse elle est assez typique
du courant sociologique dans lequel
s'inscrit Brunner qu'on pourrait appeler
la sociologie cognitive et qui s'appuie
assez largement sur les neurosciences le
problème de ce paradigme c'est qu'il est
finalement assez peu sociologique
puisque on considère par défaut qu'on a
à peu près tous le même travaux et les
mêmes façons de fonctionner et donc que
les résultats en sciences cognitive
s'appliquent à tout le monde sans
distinction évidemment je caricature
mais quand même le postulat reste un peu
celui-là et il tient pas vraiment quand
on regarde plus précisément le cerveau
c'est pas du tout le seul déterminant de
l'action et je vous renvoie vers les
très bonnes interventions du
neuroscientifique Albert moukerbert si
c'est un sujet qui vous intéresse et
globalement c'est le principal reproche
qu'on peut faire au livre de Brunner
c'est que pour un livre de sociologue il
est finalement assez peu sociologique on
manque souvent de sources véritablement
scientifique pour étayer le propos et
par exemple son concept de temps de
cerveau disponible alors ok il a
l'avantage d'être parlant mais il repose
sur pas grand chose et sa définition
reste assez floue l'analogie du marché
libre pour parler d'internet c'est un
peu pareil il présuppose qu'il y a un
marché libre mais à aucun moment on a
une analyse des structures
d'organisation d'Internet et des
stratégies de pouvoir qui s'y jouent
est-ce qu'on peut vraiment dire que nos
recherches internet révèlent notre
nature profonde sans analyser les
architectures qui sont précisément là
pour nous inciter à faire telle ou telle
chose bref je vais pas dire que le
bouquin est inintéressant parce que
c'est loin d'être le cas c'est notamment
dans ce livre là que Browner parle de
l'effet Cobra et c'est ce qui m'a donné
envie d'en faire un épisode sur la
chaîne mais il faut bien garder en tête
que on est plus de l'ordre de l'essai
que du vrai travail sociologique de
qualité et sinon j'ai lu un autre de ces
livres mais là je vais être beaucoup
plus rapide c'est son petit cabinet de
curiosité sociale paru au pif en 2018 et
en fait c'est une compilation de tous
les articles qu'il a écrit dans divers
journaux comme Le Point pour la science
ou la Revue des Deux Mondes alors là on
est loin d'un grand livre théorique
puisque c'est une succession de petits
articles de quelques pages chacun qui
aborde plein de sujets différents alors
on retrouve certaines de ces marottes
parfois un peu énervantes comme cette
diatribe contre le principe de
précaution ou des textes un peu réac
parfois mais il aborde aussi plein de
sujets super intéressant avec souvent un
angle sur la rationalité et les biais
cognitifs et moi personnellement c'est
quelque chose qui m'intéresse pas mal
en fait même de façon générale j'adore
ces livres de compilation d'articles
parce que en général ça se lit très bien
ça propose des angles intéressants sur
des faits d'actualité et celui-là ne
fait pas exception donc je vous
conseille plutôt son cabinet de
curiosité sociale mais maintenant qu'on
a fini avec le hors-top il est temps
d'entrer dans le vif du sujet donc sans
plus attendre en commence notre top 10
par
numéro 10 les gardiens de la raison
enquête sur la désinformation
scientifique publiée à la découverte par
les journalistes du Monde Stéphane Aurel
et Stéphane Foucart et par le sociologue
et maître de conférences à le Hass
Sylvain Laurent
et je me dis que c'est quand même très
ironique de vous parler de ce livre
juste après vous avez parlé de Gérald
Brunner vous allez comprendre alors
c'est un livre un peu spécial parce
qu'il est écrit à 6 mains et qui se
présente un peu comme la suite des trois
précédents livres écrits par les
différents auteurs donc Stéphane Foucart
avait publié en 2013 la fabrique du
mensonge comment les industriels
manipulent la science et nous mettent en
danger dans lequel il étudier les
manipulations scientifiques en faveur
des industriels Stefan Aurel avait
publié en 2018 lobbitomie comment les
lobbys empoisonnent nos vies et la
démocratie dans lequel elle regardait
comment les lobbys des pesticides et du
tabac de la chimie ou de l'amiante
utilise des stratégies diverses pour
continuer à disposer à diffuser des
produits nocifs et enfin Sylvain Laurent
a publié en 2019 militait pour la
science les mouvements rationalistes en
France 1930 2005 dans lequel il
regardait comment des petites
organisations rationalistes ce sont
emparés de l'espace public pour
promouvoir un certain esprit
scientifique visant à défendre la vérité
et la science
du coup le livre les gardiens de la
raison c'est un peu la continuation de
ces trois approches et l'étudie comment
la science aujourd'hui est diffusée et
vulgarisée en montrant que les
stratégies des industriels ont su
s'adapter à cette nouvelle façon
décentralisée de promouvoir l'esprit
scientifique alors avant toute chose je
vais préciser que le livre est loin
d'être parfait et de fait il a provoqué
pas mal de réactions un peu épidermique
dans les milieux scientifiques et
rationalistes mais il n'en reste pas
moins qu'il pointe des problèmes
importants et auxquels il est crucial de
réfléchir pour avoir une vision plus
réflexive de la façon dont se diffuse
les informations aujourd'hui evidemment
c'est une question qui moi me concerne
personnellement parce que je fais de la
vulgarisation sur internet je suis
membre du café des sciences et même si
en général je n'aborde pas des sujets
qui pourraient concerner des lobbys ou
des industriels ça m'embête quand même
bien de me rendre compte que j'ai malgré
moi répété les arguments concoctés par
des lobbies en étant persuadés de
relayer en consensus scientifique donc
revenons un peu plus en détail sur le
contenu du livre il commence par
présenter la façon dont le lobby des
grandes entreprises à muter depuis les
années 90 notamment après la révélation
que l'industrie du tabac a clairement
manipulé la science pour faire planer le
doute sur la dangerosité du tabac
notamment en alimentant la déviance
envers les instances gouvernementales de
régulation c'est quelque chose qui a été
très bien décrit dans le fameux livre
les marchands de doutes de Naomi ores et
Éric Conway qui retrace l'articulation
entre les tactiques sur les marchands de
tabac et les controverses sur le
réchauffement climatique l'idée c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la stratégie des lobbies
n'est plus la même et elle repose de
plus en plus largement sur le fait
d'enrôler directement des citoyens dans
les stratégies de lobbying et ça s'est
fait principalement à travers de
nombreux vulgarisateurs et passeurs de
sciences qui se proposait de mettre en
avant le rationalisme et la façon de
faire de la bonne science alors
attention c'est là qu'il faut absolument
pas caricaturer le bouquin le message du
livre c'est pas un propos complotiste
qui dirait que tout le monde est à la
botte des lobbies pas du tout l'idée
c'est plutôt de montrer comment des
personnes de bonne foi véritablement
passionné par la science et eux-mêmes
parfaitement sincère se retrouve parfois
à recycler des arguments qui sont pas
vraiment scientifiques mais que si on
remonte à la source de l'information bah
ils ont été introduits par des lobbies
et c'est justement cette circulation
horizontale de l'information qui permet
au lobby de ne pas communiquer
directement mais de distiller des
arguments au bon endroit en leur donnant
le bon enrobage de la bonne science par
exemple le livre revient assez
longuement sur le cas de laffiste
l'Association Française pour la
formation scientifique qui dirige la
revue Science et pseudosciences et il
montre qu'il participe probablement
involontairement à la propagation de
sable techno scientifique qui vise à
incriminer le principe de précaution et
les discours environnementalistes et
comme cette association jouit par
ailleurs d'une grande crédibilité
scientifique mais ça rend d'autant plus
problématique les fois où elles jouent
le rôle de quotient scientifique au
discours des industries polluantes et il
y a notamment un chapitre entier sur
Gérald Browner dont je vous parlais un
peu plus tôt qui pointe notamment
l'effet qu'il tient des positions qui
sont souvent alignées avec celles des
industriels comme le livre entier qu'il
a fait contre le principe de précaution
ou les disqualifications qu'il fait
régulièrement contre les préoccupations
écologistes lui qui est un spécialiste
de la rationalité et de la circulation
des fausses informations on retrace
ironiquement une fosse information qui
l'a participé à propager concernant les
méfaits du principe de précaution durant
l'épidémie de choléra à Haïti et même
lui a fini par reconnaître que c'était
en fait une fausse information bon
Browner a par ailleurs porté plainte en
diffamation contre les auteurs du livre
parce que il soulignait notamment que
ces derniers travaux étaient plutôt des
essais que des enquêtes scientifiques en
face avec les règles méthodologiques de
la recherche en sociologie le tribunal
judiciaire a cependant conclu qu'il n'y
avait pas de caractère diffamatoire et
qu'il s'agit plutôt d'une opinion
critique sur son travail chose que
Brunner fait d'ailleurs allègrement dans
ses propres livres du coup on a le droit
de dire que les bouquins de bonheur
manquent de soubassement scientifique
c'est bon à savoir pour finir sur le
livre comme je vous l'ai dit il est très
intéressant mais il est loin d'être
parfait là-dessus je rejoins
complètement les critiques relevées par
cumocoon dans sa recension sur le site
zététique Metacritic que je vous invite
à consulter si vous voulez aller plus
loin le livre présente certains éléments
de façon partielle il y a des choses qui
sont plus insinuées que démontré et
parfois on tombe dans l'excès inverse
quand par exemple en voulant critiquer
les méthodes des lobbys vis-à-vis des
pesticides ils en viennent à avoir des
excès de bienveillance envers d'autres
acteurs qui ont aussi dit des choses
notoirement fausses sur le sujet comme
le souligne cumocuhn tout livre voulant
dénoncer la désinformation scientifique
et notamment celle des personnalités et
des instances qui se présentent comme
rationnel et procience se doit d'être
irréprochable c'est à ce prix que
s'acquiert la crédibilité qui permet de
faire mentir les accusations
d'insinuation complotistes en l'état
actuel du fait des approximations qu'il
contient l'ouvrage rempli difficilement
ce critère cela dit ce n'est pas parce
que le livre n'est pas parfait qu'il
faut jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain
pose des questions hyper importantes sur
le pouvoir des lobbys sur la façon dont
ils peuvent exercer une emprise sur des
personnes tout à fait de bonne foi il
pose des questions institutionnelles
importantes comme par exemple tout en
passage qui est développé sur les
presses universitaires de France le puff
qui ont été rachetés par le PDG d'une
société de réassurance privée et qui
publie à la fois des livres hautement
scientifiques c'est important pour
garder une crédibilité universitaire
mais aussi des livres beaucoup plus
contestables sur le plan scientifique
comme par exemple un livre de Didier
raoultz dans la collection humaine
science ou même la quasi-totalité des
livres de Browner qui paraissent
quasiment tous aux puces bref le livre
pose des questions importantes sur les
nouvelles formes de lobbying et
l'emprise inconsciente qu'elles peuvent
causer et ils nous ont joint donc à
faire preuve d'autant plus de prudence
et de réflexivité dans nos activités de
vulgarisation je vous le conseille si
c'est un sujet qui vous intéresse
allez c'est fini pour les gardiens de la
raison on passe donc au livre suivant
numéro 9 culture de masse et société de
classe le goût de l'altérité par
Philippe coulonjon publié au pif en 2021
alors Philippe colongeon il est
directeur de recherche au CNRS
professeur à l'École doctorale de
Sciences Po et c'est un spécialiste des
questions de pratiques culturelles de
démocratisation de l'éducation et de la
façon dont se forment les échelles de
légitimité culturelle ce sont des
questions qui à titre personnel me
passionnent et d'ailleurs Philippe
colongeon a été mon directeur de mémoire
quand j'étais moi-même en master le
livre culture de masse et société de
classe se présente donc comme une somme
qui revient sur presque 50 ans de
recherche sur les pratiques culturelles
et qui réactualisent tout ça avec les
derniers travaux sur le sujet en faisant
dialoguer une littérature très variée et
internationale c'est peut-être même
presque le seul reproche qu'on pourrait
lui faire c'est qu'effectivement c'est
extrêmement dense c'est précis mais du
coup ça se lit pas comme un roman quoi
moi c'est des questions qui
m'intéressent et j'ai pas mal lu sur ces
sujets là mais parfois il fallait que je
m'accroche un petit peu vous pas perdre
le fil du raisonnement en fait on va
très loin dans les diverses controverses
et surtout les nuances qu'on doit
apporter à telle ou telle vision qui
serait trop simplificatrice enfin c'est
surtout vrai pour les premières parties
qui reviennent dans une perspective
historique sur toute la période de
démocratisation culturelle et scolaire
avec tous les débats qui ont entouré ces
notions puis dans un second temps on
nous présente davantage les résultats
d'une recherche très contemporaine et
originales dans la structuration des
profils culturels l'un des points que
moi je trouve particulièrement
intéressant c'est tout ce qui est
développé sur la modification des
hiérarchies culturelles telles qu'elles
avaient été mises en évidence par
Bourdieu dans la distinction pour le
coup alors c'est pas du tout des choses
nouvelles et on observe déjà depuis un
certain temps que les différences de
légitimité culturelle elle ne se font
plus tellement entre la culture de
l'élite d'un côté et la culture
populaire de l'autre mais ça se fait
plutôt entre un modèle qu'on appelle
univore
omnivore ça c'est quelque chose que le
sociologue Richard Peterson avait mis en
évidence dans les années deux indices
c'est à dire que l'opposition elle ne se
fait plus entre d'un côté les gens qui
écoutent de l'Opéra et de l'autre les
gens qui écoutent du rap mais plutôt
entre des personnes qui consomment de
tout donc de l'Opéra comme du rap mais
aussi du jazz du rock et de l'électro
par exemple ça ce serait les omnivores
et puis les personnes qui sont
qualifiées du niveau qui n'ont qu'un
seul mode de consommation culturelle
pour rester dans mon exemple celle qui
consomerait que durable ce qui est très
différent de ce qui étudier Bourdieu
dans les années 60 mais ce que montre
coulongeon c'est que le fait que les
dominants se mettent à consommer aussi
des produits culturels populaires ça n'a
pas pour autant fait disparaître les
frontières de légitimité et il analyse
plutôt la montée d'un capital
multiculturel et de l'importance de la
réflexivité dans ce type de consommation
en clair c'est maintenant dans la façon
de consommer les mêmes produits un savon
comme populaire qu'on va trouver les
principaux effets de la distinction par
exemple imaginez quelqu'un qui parlerait
pendant des heures de contenu issus de
la culture populaire mais pour faire des
analyses réflexives et sociologiques et
des supports de vulgarisation bon bah là
on serait carrément dans une
appropriation distinctive de ces œuvres
attends quoi finalement dans la dernière
partie coulongeons approfondie ces
questions à partir d'une base de données
récentes et particulièrement
intéressante il met notamment en avant
un facteur général qui vient
considérablement complexifier
l'opposition entre savants et légitime
par une subdivision secondaire entre le
capital établi et le capital émergent
justement mais tout ça ça mène quand
même à montrer que malgré un gros
brouillage des frontières les effets de
domination et d'exclusion reste toujours
bien présent le truc super intéressant
c'est que ces différents profils ils
peuvent aussi entrer en relation avec
des orientations politiques et
idéologiques en gros prolongeon veut
montrer que contrairement à ce qu'on dit
partout le vote de classe n'a pas
disparu il s'est juste transformé et
pour ça il montre qu'on peut analyser
l'électorat actuel selon deux grandes
variables principales qui expliquent la
plus grande variation des votes le degré
de généralisme culturel et le degré de
libéralisme économique et la grande
différence avec le passé c'est que
aujourd'hui c'est le libéralisme
culturel qui est devenu plus structurant
que le libéralisme économique du coup en
faisant des belles analyses factorielles
de correspondance il montre qu'on peut
ranger les individus dans 4 grands
profils politiques donc en bas gauche on
a les gens très libéraux économiquement
mais conservateur culturellement ça on
pourrait dire que c'est des gens
traditionnellement de droite à l'opposé
on a les gens libéraux culturellement
mais pas économiquement on pourrait dire
que c'est les personnes
traditionnellement de gauche mais on a
aussi des profils libéraux culturels et
économiques globalement ok pour les
droits LGBT mais il faut une économie de
marché mondialisée et de l'autre côté on
a un profil purement anti libéral c'est
à dire conservateur sur le plan de
valeur et contre le libéralisme
économique
alors ces données elles ont été obtenues
sur un assez petit échantillon mais
c'est des résultats super intéressants
et ce serait cool de regarder ça sur des
échantillons plus larges et surtout de
comparer avec d'autres pays voilà du
coup si vous pensez que c'est des
questions qui peuvent vous intéresser je
vous conseille la lecture de culture de
masse et société de classe et pour le
coup vous pouvez être sûr que c'est un
livre super dense
ultra solide et basé scientifiquement
parlant n'hésitez pas à me dire en
commentaire si c'est des sujets que vous
aimeriez que j'aborde plus longuement
parce que ça fait un moment que je
cherche l'angle parfait pour aborder les
questions de légitimité culturelle sur
la chaîne même si je sais que je le
ferai un moment ou un autre en attendant
on passe au numéro suivant
numéro 8 les candidats novissent et
professionnels en politique de Etienne
Aulion paru au puff en 2021 alors ce
livre là je l'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé
de toute façon je les ai tous aimés
puisque on est dans mon top 10 mais bon
celui-là c'est un livre clair accessible
et surtout si vous avez envie de mieux
connaître comment fonctionne le
Parlement et quels sont les enjeux du
mandat de députés je ne peux que vous
conseiller de vous plonger dans les
candidats alors Étienne Aulion il est
directeur de recherche au CNRS
professeur à Polytechnique et c'est le
grand spécialiste de l'Assemblée
nationale en fait il avait déjà fait un
long travail à l'assemblée qui avait
donné le Livre métier député dans lequel
il étudier principalement la
professionnalisation de la fonction
députée c'était un gros travail qui
portait sur cinq législatures de 1978 à
2017 et qui reconstituait près de 2400
carrières complètes de députés et puis
lorsque les élections de 2017 ont eu
lieu et qu'on a vu énormément de
personnes qu'il avait jamais eu de
mandat politique auparavant les fameux
novices accédés à la fonction de députée
il s'est dit que c'était vraiment trop
con de pas aller étudier cette plus près
et du coup il a rempilé en ouvrant un
nouveau terrain de recherche sur la
mandature 2017-2022 du coup quand il
commence à étudier les députés
macronistes ça fait déjà un moment qu'il
traîne à l'Assemblée nationale et qui
fait des entretiens à droite à gauche et
limite il connaît mieux le métier que
quoi du coup ça fait que ce livre est un
document précieux parce que c'est le
meilleur bilan qu'on puisse faire des
députés macronistes à l'Assemblée
d'ailleurs j'ai été assez étonné qu'en
2022 il ne soit pas davantage invité sur
les plateaux pour discuter des élections
là où toutes les chaînes essayer de
dégainer leurs experts on l'a quand même
un petit peu vu sur Mediapart ils savent
visiblement bien choisir pour
intervenants des gens véritablement
spécialistes merci Edwy
mais alors du coup qu'est-ce que ça a
donné cette élection de 2017 le premier
concept central du livre c'est celui de
contournement de la file d'attente en
fait ce qu'on voit c'est que depuis pas
mal d'années il fallait attendre de plus
en plus longtemps pour pouvoir devenir
député en gros il y a un certain nombre
d'étapes d'abord il faut être militant
puis qu'on s'est municipal assistant
parlementaire puis au bout d'un moment
tu peux être investi d'abord dans une
circonscription pas gagnantable et au
bout d'un moment dans une
circonscription gagnable et quand on
regarde sur ces dernières années ce
temps d'attente avant d'être élu député
il s'est considérablement allongé
puisque on est passé en 40 ans de 5,7
ans à 11,6 ans donc autant dire qu'il y
a plein de gens qui étaient hyper
frustrés de ce cursus honoro obligatoire
et que du coup quand Macron débarque en
2017 et qui recrute en deux spi plein de
nouveaux députés en speed dating pour
l'élection législative mais ça
court-circuite complètement cette file
d'attente et ça permet à plein de monde
de se faire élire sans avoir à passer
toutes ces étapes attendues ça on se
voit clairement dans les statistiques
parce que on a beaucoup plus de Primo
députés la moyenne d'âge à l'Assemblée
elle passe par exemple de 56 ans à 49
ans et quand on regarde les élus on voit
que les députés macronistes ont moyenne
ils ont 5,6 ans d'anciennetés en
politique là où c'est plutôt 20 ans pour
les élus LR ou PS bon du coup ce
renouveau c'est bien sympa mais ça aussi
un effet pervers c'est que les nouveaux
venus ben ils connaissent mal voir pas
du tout le métier de parlementaire parce
que justement ils ont pas fait toutes
ces étapes comme assistant parlementaire
etc par conséquent ils vont être très
inégaux dans leur capacité à investir la
fonction en particulier Étienne au lion
montre que chez les députés macronistes
c'est surtout ce qui avait un petit peu
d'ancienneté qui vont réussir à tirer
leur épingle du jeu on se place en
stratégiquement dès le début soit dans
les médias soit dans les commissions les
plus importantes justement parce que ils
connaissent les bails là où les nouveaux
venus ils vont rester dans des positions
un peu subalternes et ils vont être
utilisés principalement pour faire
nombre pendant les votes ça rej un petit
peu l'accusation qu'on a beaucoup vu de
députés Playmobil et justement le livre
montre très bien comment beaucoup de ces
nouveaux députés ont été assez désabusés
en fait par la découverte de ce métier
et des contraintes réelles qu'ils font
peser donc les rythmes étranges la
lenteur de ce travail la jeune d'accue
chargé des violences parfois très
concurrentielles etc etc du coup déjà
que le renouvellement social a été
quasiment inexistant puisque les
nouveaux venus appartiennent très
majoritairement à des catégories
favorisées le renouvellement politique
en lui-même il a été assez timide parce
que c'est surtout des anciens de la
politique qui ont pu tirer des avantages
en coupant la file d'attente habituelle
un autre grand apport de l'étude c'est
qu'il utilise plein de matériaux à la
fois quantitatif et qualitatifs pour
mesurer les usages différenciés qui sont
faits du Parlement par les différentes
députés un traitement statistique
complexe permet par exemple cette
représentation stylisée des pratiques à
l’assemblée selon notamment la
visibilité des députés et on voit que
les positions sur cette figure varient
fort ement selon les parties on voit par
exemple que les députés de la République
en marche sont nombreux à être anonymes
et cantonné au scrutin ou à la
circonscription tandis que les quelques
députés de la France insoumise ils sont
plutôt assez visibles alors même que
c'est plutôt assez difficile d'accéder
au coin nord-est de la carte et ils ont
plutôt tendance à se servir de
l'Assemblée comme d'une tribune
politique
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur cette
modélisation là je vous mettrai un lien
vers une conférence qu'il a donné à
l'Institut Poincaré où il détaille un
petit peu les modèles d'intelligence
artificielle qu'il a utilisé pour
modéliser le travail parlementaire
finalement Étienne porte aussi un autre
constat sur l'évolution du métier député
c'est celui de la baisse d'attractivité
alors de fait un 65 % des députés
appartiennent encore au catégories
supérieures ça il y a pas de problème
mais on voit que ces chiffres sont
plutôt en baisse pour le très très haut
du panier les professions libérales par
exemple sont passées de 12 à 6% et la
part des hauts fonctionnaires elle elle
a baissé de 13,4% à 6,6% entre 78 et
2017 pour expliquer ça on peut regarder
l'affaiblissement du parlementarisme et
l'augmentation de la défiance mais il
faut aussi voir que les conditions de
travail se sont particulièrement
dégradées la charge de travail par
exemple elle a considérablement augmenté
au début du 20e siècle on était à peu
près à 25000 heures de séances là où
dans les années 90 on était à 50 000
heures et aujourd'hui on est plutôt de
l'ordre de 60
et dans le même temps le travail de
député rapporte moins même si on reste
dans le très haut du panier on est passé
du top 1% des rémunérations au top 3% ce
qui s'explique principalement par le
décrochage des très hauts revenus dans
les catégories supérieures mais ce qui
contribue à faire de cette activité
quelque chose de moins attractif pour
les classes très supérieures au final le
constat est que le mandat de député a
perdu de sa noblesse et qu'il est
peut-être en train de devenir ce que
David griber appelle un bullshitjob on
en reparlera au passage le livre parle
assez longuement de François Fillon et
du coup ça fait toujours plaisir de lui
remettre une petite couche et notamment
il prend le cassillon comme un exemple
un peu prototypique du député de
carrière qui voit son prestige social se
dégrader et le fait de replacer son cas
dans l'histoire longue de la machine
parlementaire ça permet aussi
d'expliquer certains de ses
comportements attention j'ai dit
expliquer foutrement pas excusé voilà
donc je vous conseille très largement le
livre d'Etienne au lion si vous voulez
en savoir plus sur la mandature des
macronistes et sur le métier de député
en général je ne sais pas s'il a prévu u
de poursuivre son terrain pour cette
mandature actuelle il y en a peut-être
un petit peu marre de passer sa vie à
l'Assemblée depuis tout ce temps mais ce
serait assez cool de regarder les
recompositions qui sont faites depuis
l'élection de 2022 avec l'absence de
majorité absolue et ce serait surtout
intéressant de voir si on a à nouveau un
grand renouvellement ou si les anciens
novices ont rempilés pour 50 plus et ce
que ça change dans leur façon d'incarner
le métier plein de belles questions en
perspective mais en attendant on passe
au livre suivant
numéro 7 la fascination de l'ogre ou
comment desserrer les taux de la finance
de Laurent sialom publié chez Fayard en
2019 et oui parce que je ne lis pas que
de la sociologie j'essaye de lire aussi
régulièrement des travaux en économie
même si la langue est plutôt celui de
l'économie institutionnelle c'est à dire
un port de l'économie qui ne s'intéresse
pas uniquement à des modèles abstraits
mais à comment fonctionne réellement les
institutions c'est un peu la version la
plus sociologique de l'économie on
pourrait dire alors pour vous présenter
rapidement Laurent sialom elle est
professeure à l'Université de Paris
Nanterre elle est spécialiste d'économie
financière est plus particulièrement des
politiques macro-prudentielles je sais
ça fait beaucoup de gros mots elle est
notamment membre de plusieurs conseils
spécialisés et elles fournit
régulièrement des analyses pour l'ONG
final Swatch qui garde un œil sur les
dérives du monde de la finance alors le
point de départ du livre c'est déjà
qu'il y a énormément de problèmes dans
le monde de la finance d'aujourd'hui
décrit mon col blanc un manque de
régulation des conflits d'intérêts bref
mais surtout le problème c'est que on
parle très peu de ces questions là parce
que la finance c'est vu comme un truc
technique et hyper compliqué et du coup
c'est difficile de s'y attaquer
véritablement l'ambition du livre est
donc de rendre accessible un maximum de
ces mécanismes et de faire comprendre
les irrégularités du monde de la finance
pour que ces sujets soient davantage
discutés dans la sphère publique un peu
ce que je suis en train de faire là
comme elle l'écrit dans son introduction
Laurent sialom a été poussé à écrire ce
livre en lisant les marchands de doutes
l'ouvrage de ores et Conway dont on a
déjà parlé un peu plus tôt et dans
lequel il décortique comment les lobbies
industriels et notamment celui du tabac
ont élaboré une stratégie très efficace
pour éviter ou affaiblir toute
réglementation qui pourrait nuire à
leurs intérêts sa thèse est donc que le
même genre de constat peut être fait à
propos de la finance qui semble
gangrener par un lobby bancaire
extrêmement puissant elle souligne non
sans humour qu'elle travaille depuis de
très nombreuses années sur ces questions
là puisque elle avait réussi à monter un
cours de régulation macroprientielle
niveau Master 2 des 2004 mais à l'époque
cette question d'intéressait pas grand
monde tout le monde s'en foutait un peu
autant vous dire que ça a bien changé
après la crise de 2008 ou d'un coup elle
s'est mise à recevoir beaucoup plus de
demandes pour intervenir sur ces
questions-là on comprend pourquoi alors
avant d'aller plus loin il faut que je
vous explique très rapidement un terme
important je vous ai dit que Laurent
sialom elle est spécialiste de politique
macroprudentiels mais qu'est-ce que ça
peut bien vouloir dire en fait pour
comprendre il faut réussir à faire la
différence avec son appel une politique
microprudentielle l'idée c'est que pour
ne pas faire faillite une banque elle
doit se protéger contre les risques par
exemple elle doit avoir une quantité
suffisante de fonds propres elle doit
pas créer trop de monnaies ou bien elle
doit pas avoir des positions trop risqué
sur les marchés financiers et quand on
essaye de rendre chaque banque
individuellement plus solide on parle de
politique microprudentiel le problème
c'est que contrairement à ce qu'on a
longtemps cru et ben ça suffit pas pour
avoir un système financier solide il ne
suffit pas que chaque élément pris
isolément soit plus solide parce que ça
ne protège pas contre les risques de
système en gros c'est l'idée que si une
banque fait faillite on pensait avant
que c'était normalement pas trop grave
du moment que les autres banques étaient
solides ça devait tenir le coup le
problème c'est que comme toutes les
banques font à peu près les mêmes trucs
si on a une qui fait faillite il y a de
fortes chances que ce soit parce que un
marché s'est cassé la gueule et du coup
les autres banques vont être elles aussi
fragilisées alors si en plus elle
possédait des titres de la banque qui a
fait faillite alors là c'est fini on
risque l'effondrement du système tout
entier et c'est un peu ce qui s'est
passé en 2008 avec la faillite de Lehman
Brothers je précise que je simplifie
beaucoup là et du coup les politiques
macroprudentielles c'est des politiques
plus globales et qui vise à nous
protéger contre un risque systémique des
marchés financiers en gros c'est ce qui
évite qu'on perd de toute notre épargne
chaque fois qu'un P d'influenceur fait
trembler tous Wall Street le livre
commence donc par faire un résumé de
toute la littérature économique parue
sur l'instabilité financière donc les
liens entre les bulles de crédit et les
bulles financières immobilières
l'illusion selon laquelle les marchés
financiers fonctionneraient toujours
parfaitement la tendance à
l'hypertrophie de la finance bon tout
est expliqué donc je vous invite à lire
le livre s'il y a des trucs que vous
aimeriez mieux comprendre sur ces
sujets-là sinon il y a bien sûr la
chaîne de Eurêka vous connaissez depuis
le temps ensuite dans la partie que je
trouve plus intéressantes et plus
institutionnelle elle pointe les
multiples conflits d'intérêts dans
lesquels baignent les banques elle fait
une analyse de ce qu'elle appelle la
capture c'est-à-dire l'ensemble des
multiples canaux par lesquels
l'industrie financière pèse sur les
processus de décision politique pour
servir leur propre intérêts outre le
lobbying classique et agressif que l'on
peut imaginer un des points les plus
intéressants du livre c'est de montrer
la capture cognitive qui est à l'oeuvre
le monde de la finance contrôle votre
cerveau non mais le fait est que
l'économie mainstream néolibérale c'est
tellement imposé partout à la fois dans
les départements de recherche d'économie
mais aussi chez les décideurs publics
qu'il règne un climat intelle actuelle
de défiance vis-à-vis des
réglementations qui sont accusées de ne
plus servir que des intérêts privés et
de générer des distorsions de
concurrence au détriment du consommateur
dans le domaine de la finance
l'hypothèse dominante de l'efficience
des marchés financiers des anticipations
rationnelles et la représentation des
crises comme le résultat d'un choc
exogène on conduit à se convaincre du
caractère néfaste et même
contre-productif d'une régulation
étatique et en conclure que la sphère
financière pouvait s'auto réguler
s'auto réguler oui je crois qu'on peut
être d'accord sur le fait que ça marche
plutôt bien c'est encore plus visible
dans le secteur bancaire ou les
régulations sont bien en dessous de ce
qu'on pourrait espérer comme je vous
l'ai dit les banques elles doivent
suivre des règles en termes de
capitalisation ou de position risqué sur
les marchés financiers mais dans les
faits on laisse les banques utiliser
leur propre modèle d'évaluation des
risques pour le calcul dont le ratio de
capital réglementaire c'est un peu comme
si on laissait un conducteur donner
lui-même une approximation de la
quantité d'alcool qu'il a dans le sang
en le croyant sur parole et vérifier
derrière et c'est pas fini parce que le
livre mais aussi en évidence une
généralisation de ce qu'on appelle les
revolving Doors entre le monde des
banques et celui de la finance en gros
il est pas rare que le PDG d'une grande
banque ou d'un fond de pension soit
engagé comme président de la commission
chargée d'évaluer et de sanctionner les
risques financiers c'est un peu comme si
on engageait un ex grand patron de labo
pharmaceutique pour gérer les
autorisations de mise sur le marché des
médicaments ça veut pas dire qu'il
serait forcément biaisé dans son travail
mais on est quand même en droit de se
poser la question mais d'ailleurs la
question elle se pose même pas parce
qu'il y a des études qui ont été faites
à ce sujet et qui montrent que les
superviseurs ayant eu antérieurement des
fonctions et ou un mandat dans le
secteur financier sont prédisposés à une
plus grande identification sociale avec
celui-ci ce qui impacte négativement
leur performance en tant que superviseur
une autre étude de 2017 a montré que la
proportion des gouverneurs de banques
centrales qui avaient un passé dans la
finance il est passé de 10% en 1980 à
30% en et surtout on voit que un
banquier devenu banquier central
dérégule trois fois plus qu'en banquier
central sans expérience dans la finance
donc on voit vraiment un effet de cette
capture cognitive du monde de la finance
dans les politiques qui sont menées si
on a été un banquier pendant
suffisamment longtemps on pense comme un
banquier et du coup on n'est pas un bon
régulateur mais bon ça visiblement
personne ne s'en est aperçu parmi ceux
qui désignent les banquiers centraux
d'ailleurs ça m'étonnerait pas que ce
soit aussi des anciens banquiers on en a
un comme président il n'y a qu'à voir ce
que ça donne pour finir Laurence stalom
propose des pistes pour desserrer cette
étau de la finance et ses articules
autour de deux éléments alors déjà
réduire le pouvoir de capture de la
finance en luttant contre les lobbys
contre le pantouflage et surtout en
rendant moins
inutilement complexe le monde de la
finance pour que tout le monde puisse se
saisir de ses enjeux mais d'autre part
et c'est en gros morceaux refondre
complètement la discipline économique
tant sur l'enseignement que du point de
vue de la recherche je suis déjà revenu
dans mes précédentes vidéos sur le fait
que la science économique manque de
diversité et qu'elle est dominée par un
paradigme mainstream et Laurent sialom
plaide pour une approche beaucoup plus
large des enjeux économiques bref c'est
un livre extrêmement intéressant et
utile d'un point de vue citoyen certains
passages pourront vous paraître un peu
technique si vous êtes vraiment
allergique à la finance mais il y a
vraiment un gros travail de pédagogie et
surtout le livre est extrêmement solide
et d'un point de vue scientifique tout
est sourcé documenté démontré et le
livre est riche de propositions
politiques je vous le conseille très
chaudement si c'est des questions qui
vous intéressent quant à nous on passe
au livre suivant
numéro 6 boule shits Jobs de David
Grabber paru en français en 2018 au lien
qui libère et celui-là je peux pas vous
le montrer parce que je l'ai lu en livre
audio vous avez sûrement déjà entendu
parler des bullshit Jobs de David Graber
qu'on a traduit souvent en français par
les jobs à la con et qui sont devenus
une réelle épidémie de notre modernité
alors David Grabber c'était un
anthropologue américain à la London
School a fait économics et il nous a
malheureusement quitté en 2020 et c'est
aussi un militant anarchiste qui a été à
l'avant-garde du mouvement occupa et
Wall Street signe figure assez
particulière parce que c'est un
chercheur
ultra sérieux et bien implanté dans le
monde académique mais il est également
très populaire et ses livres sont lus
par une grande partie de la population
d'ailleurs une de ces marques de
fabrique c'est que tout en étant
exigeant sur le plan scientifique ces
livres sont très accessibles et il écrit
avec un style très agréable à la fois
simple et pas mal ponctuée d'humour un
de ces livres les plus célèbres c'est
sans doute dette 5000 ans d'histoire
dont ils imitent avait fait une
présentation brillante et très complète
sur sa chaîne en deux vidéos de près
d'une heure chacune donc si le sujet
vous intéresse vous savez quoi faire
par la suite il a aussi écrit sur les
déboires de la bureaucratie dans son
livre bureaucratie l'utopie des règles
paru en 2015 et c'est un peu dans cette
même veine que Paris en 2018 ce gros
bangerz qui est bullshit Jobs donc si ce
n'est pas encore assez explicite je vous
recommande très fortement la lecture de
ce livre c'est intelligent c'est drôle
ça si tout seul et ça apporte des
réflexions vraiment lumineuses sur notre
organisation du travail déjà on commence
par une petite définition David griber
définit les bullshits Jobs comme une
forme d'emplois rémunérée si totalement
inutile superflu ou néfaste que même le
salarié ne parvient pas à justifier son
existence bien qu'il se sente obligé de
faire croire le contraire c'est des
métiers qu'on va retrouver beaucoup dans
la finance par exemple ou dans le monde
des avocats d'affaires et il y a déjà un
truc important de cette définition c'est
sa dimension subjective c'est le
sentiment intime de faire un métier
complètement
inutile voire carrément néfaste egreber
soutient que c'est là une grande source
d'insatisfaction voire de souffrance
psychologique parce que intérieurement
tout le monde voudrait être utile l'idée
du livre est donc né dans Courbier
d'humeur qu'il avait initialement publié
en 2013 dans LA REVUE ANARCHISTE strike
qui a fait un énorme buzz sur le net et
qui a suscité une avalanche de
témoignages de travailleurs qui s'y
reconnaissait c'est donc directement sur
Twitter que Graber a récolté une grande
partie des témoignages et des
contributions qui lui ont permis
d'affiner ses recherches et de produire
une typologie des bullshits job il
divise donc les bullshitjob en 5 grandes
catégories les larbins les porte
flingues les rafistolaires les cocheurs
de cases et les petits chefs alors je
vais vous détailler un petit peu tout ça
les larbins ou les faire valoir ils ne
servent qu'à mettre en valeur la
hiérarchie ou la clientèle typiquement
le métier de portier qui pourrait
facilement être remplacé par
l'interphone mais il ne servent que à
faire prestige deuxièmement on a les
portefles ou les sbires dont le boulot a
une composante agressive mais surtout
qu'il n'existe que parce que la fonction
a été déjà créée par d'autres boîtes
différentes par exemple un pays n'a
besoin d'une armée que parce que les
autres pays en ont une alors c'est un
exemple un Graber ne dit pas du tout que
l'armée est un bullshit job en soi par
contre les lobbyistes les experts en
relation publique les télévendeurs les
avocats d'affaires c'est autre chose la
particularité du portefeuille c'est pas
seulement qu'il n'apporte rien à la
société mais c'est qu'ils ont carrément
un impact négatif troisièmement on a les
rafistolaires ça c'est ceux qui sont là
uniquement pour résoudre des problèmes
qui auraient dû être évitées
dans le boulot et de réparer les dégâts
causés par des supérieurs hiérarchiques
incompétents ou par exemple tous les
métiers du type médiateur interne qui
doit résoudre des conflits entre
différents départements qui pourraient
être évités si les employés
communiquaient ou si l'organisation du
travail était un petit peu plus efficace
quatrièmement on a ce qu'il appelle les
cocheurs de cases qui sont
principalement recrutés pour permettre à
une organisation de prétendre qu'elle
traite un problème mais qu'elle a aucune
intention de résoudre réellement on a
par exemple le cas d'une jeune femme
dont le rôle était de coordonner des
activités de loisirs au sein d'une
maison de retraite mais que en réalité
elle passait plus de temps à faire
remplir des formulaires sur leurs envies
au pensionnaires plutôt qu'à s'occuper
vraiment d'organiser des activités et
enfin la dernière catégorie c'est la
catégorie des petits chefs eux ils sont
là pour surveiller des personnes qui
travaillent déjà de façon parfaitement
autonome et avec une prime pour les
petits chefs qui s'ennuient et qui du
coup vont créer des missions à la con ou
qui recrutent pour des boulots à la con
ça c'est ce que David gripper appelle
bullshitiser la vie des autres bref
comme vous pouvez le sentir ne serait-ce
qu'avec la terminologie c'est un livre
assez drôle qui fourmille de plein de
petits exemples rigolos ou affligent
c'est selon mais il y a aussi des
réflexions vraiment intéressantes sur la
façon dont la boule utilisation du monde
du travail a profondément transformé
l'organisation sociale et la hiérarchie
des normes par exemple il se pose la
question toute simple de savoir pourquoi
beaucoup de ces bullshits Jobs néfastes
comme les financiers ou les avocats
d'affaires sont très bien payés alors
qu'à l'inverse on a job ultra importants
qui sont considérablement sous-payés
prendre l'exemple des professeurs ou des
professions médicales et bien son
hypothèse c'est que c'est tellement
inconfortable psychiquement de faire un
bullshit job qu'il faut au moins une
forte rémunération pour supporter le
fait d'être inutile ou néfaste alors
qu'à l'inverse on voit souvent
l'argument de la vocation qu'on les
professeurs ou les infirmières demandent
des augmentations en fait c'est un peu
comme si on nous disait non mais c'est
bon vous vous avez déjà un métier utile
socialement et relativement prestigieux
en termes symbolique vous allez pas en
plus demander une rémunération monétaire
et je dois dire que ça fait pas mal de
sens bref évidemment là je raccourci
l'argument parce qu'il souligne bien
qu'il existe évidemment des bullshit
Jobs mal payés mais je trouve cette
façon de regarder la rémunération d'un
métier comme corréler négativement à son
utilité sociale comme assez intéressante
comme je vous l'ai dit le livre fait
réfléchir à plein de trucs super
intéressant et si je devais pointer une
limite je rejoindrai la critique de
Thomas coutreau dans sa recension qui
est le fait que Graber face en fait très
peu référence aux sciences du travail
préexistantes ce qui rend un peu plus
faible les pistes de solutions
envisagées pour résoudre le problème
cela dit ça reste une lecture hyper fun
et stimulante et je vous conseille
vivement bullshitsubs de David Graber
alors attention parce que là on était
déjà dans le lourd et on rentre dans le
top 5
numéro 5 le mythe du déficit la théorie
moderne de la monnaie et la naissance de
l'économie du peuple de Stéphanie Kelton
publié au lien qui libère en 2022 alors
à nouveau c'est un livre d'économie et
je vais avoir du mal à vous dire grand
chose de plus que lisez le que vous ayez
ou pas du mal avec l'économie lisez-le
c'est un bijou de clarté et ça retourne
complètement la façon de voir le
fonctionnement du système économique
Stéphanie Kelton je vous la présente
rapidement américaine professeur
d'économie et de politique publique à
l'université de stony blues à New York
il a été conseillère économique pour
plusieurs décideurs publics notamment au
sein du parti démocrate elle en parle un
petit peu de dans le livre quant elle
montre que les politiques ne comprennent
à peu près rien au fonctionnement du
système économique bon alors pour vous
expliquer le point de départ du livre le
but est de présenter la nouvelle théorie
monétaire qui espère remplacer la
vieille façon de concevoir l'économie
surtout porter par le monétarisme ça
commence par le constat de comment est
créé la monnaie donc je refais un petit
peu d'histoire de la pensée pendant
longtemps on a cru que lorsque les
banques font un crédit à quelqu'un elles
se contentait de prêter l'épargne des
autres déposants en gros on pensait que
la banque n'avait qu'un rôle
d'intermédiaire entre des agents en
capacité de financement des agents ont
besoin de financement mais ce dont on
s'est aperçu en regardant dans le détail
c'est que ça marche pas du tout comme ça
en fait lorsqu'une banque fait un crédit
elle crée de la monnaie qui n'existait
pas auparavant en fait la monnaie c'est
juste une ligne de code sur compte du
coup quand une banque vous prête disons
100000 euros elle écrivait juste 100000
euros sur votre compte sans que cet
argent ne soit soustrait nulle part
ailleurs on parle de création monétaire
ex nihilo ce dont je vous parle là c'est
pas une théorie c'est le consensus
économique on sait que ça marche comme
ça c'est même dans les programmes
scolaires de sciences économique et
sociales et je vous invite à poncer la
chaîne Eurêka si jamais vous voulez en
savoir plus
je vous dis ça parce que c'était cette
fête il a été un peu dur à avaler pour
pas mal d'économistes et surtout pour
pas mal de politique et bien souvent ils
ont continué à être voir une vision de
l'économie qu'on pourrait qualifier de à
l'ancienne et maintenant on peut dire
que la nouvelle théorie monétaire c'est
un courant un peu hétérodoxe de
l'économie qui entend tiré pleinement
les conséquences de la façon dont la
monnaie est réellement créée et donc de
l'appliquer notamment à la question des
déficits publics du coup je vous
conseille vraiment de lire le livre
parce qu'il est très pédagogique et
surtout assez inédit en fait Stéphanie
Kelton
prend la façon qu'on a de voir
habituellement l'économie elle te
retourne complètement le truc et elle te
dit bon tu vois ce machin qu'on avait
l'impression que ça fonctionnait comme
ça et ben en fait ça fonctionne comme ça
et surtout elle le démontre de façon
assez indiscutable du coup la grosse
thèse du livre c'est notamment qu'on se
fourvoie complètement quand on parle des
déficits et de la dette publique parce
qu'en fait
c'est pas de la dette c'est plutôt de la
création monétaire alors là-dessus il
faut préciser qu'elle parle surtout dans
le contexte des États-Unis c'est-à-dire
une puissance qui a une monnaie Fiat
c'est-à-dire qu'elle peut contrôler par
sa banque centrale en France par exemple
on n'a pas le contrôle de notre
politique monétaire puisque on est dans
la zone euro et du coup c'est la BCE la
Banque centrale européenne qui détermine
la politique monétaire et nous on fait
pas ce qu'on veut mais je vais rester en
France pour donner un exemple je sais
pas si vous savez mais en France
aujourd'hui on est endetté à environ
110% du PIB et on a environ 20% de la
dette française qui possédait par la BCE
ce que ça veut dire c'est que la BCE
elle a créé de la monnaie pour acheter
de la dette française à d'autres acteurs
économiques par exemple des banques ou
des fonds de pension mais imaginons que
demain la BCE décide d'annuler cette
dette qu'est-ce qui se passerait
et bien en fait d'après Stéphanie Kelton
rien la seule chose c'est que la monnaie
que la banque a créé pour acheter la
dette ne serait pas détruite parce que
du coup on aurait plus besoin de la
rembourser mais sinon c'est tout et du
coup ça ferait passer la dette publique
française immédiatement à environ 80% de
dates sur PIB et c'est ça qui faut
retenir c'est que globalement la banque
centrale elle a un pouvoir de création
monétaire illimité donc ça va pas de
sens pour elle de parler de dette
publique quand un état a le contrôle de
sa politique monétaire par exemple aux
États-Unis on pourrait imaginer qu'on
arrête complètement de lever des impôts
et qu'on finance tout par la création
monétaire on paye les infrastructures
les fonctionnaires les prisons tout par
de la création monétaire on ne prélevant
aucun impôt et pourquoi pas la fête peut
créer autant de dollars qu'elle veut
alors autant qu'elle veut quand même pas
les tenants de la nouvelle théorie
monétaire ne plaide pas non plus pour
une création monétaire imitée bien au
contraire mais selon eux il y a qu'un
seul critère important c'est l'inflation
en gros si on crée beaucoup d'argent
mais que l'économie est capable
d'encaisser de s'adapter et qu'on
augmente la production sans augmenter
les prix pas de problème mais si à
l'inverse d'un coup on crée plein
d'argent ou qu'on arrête de prélever les
impôts et que ça se traduit par des gros
chocs de demandes qui provoquent de
l'inflation alors là il faut ralentir
parce que ça veut dire qu'on a les trop
vite pour l'économie d'ailleurs dans
cette optique elle soutient que la seule
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement
doit prélever des impôts c'est pas pour
se financer parce que comme on l'a dit
on peut créer toute la monnaie qui veut
il en a pas besoin mais c'est avant tout
pour enlever de la richesse aux gens
pour éviter les tensions inflationnistes
du coup la seule boussole que devrait
avoir les visiteurs publics c'est le
niveau d'inflation et pas du tout la
quantité de dettes publiques qui elle ne
signifie rien et au moment où Kelton
publie le livre l'inflation était très
basse donc ça appelait à plus de
création monétaire évidemment les
préconisations seraient bien différentes
aujourd'hui ou l'inflation est revenue
je précise quand même que j'ai
volontairement simplifié le propos par
souci de clart bien sûr il y a des
débats concernant les effets que pour
avoir l'annulation de la dette publique
par la Banque centrale mais je vous
présente la version qui est
principalement présentée dans le livre
et puis je vous laisserai vous
renseigner si vous voulez voir les
critiques qui sont faites de cette
vision là par les économistes mainstream
un autre élément important du livre
c'est de montrer à quel point le
personnel politique comprend en fait peu
de choses au débat économique et que du
coup ça participe à compliquer
considérablement l'action de l'État elle
bouillonne assez longuement par exemple
sur un dispositif États-Unis qui
s'appelle le Pego qui empêche le
Parlement de passer une loi sans devoir
trouver une source immédiate de
financement soit en augmentant les
impôts soit en baissant les dépenses
ailleurs et surtout elle montre que les
politiques oublient bien souvent que la
dette est aussi utile parce qu'elle est
source de richesse et d'épargne stable
sous la forme de bons du Trésor par
exemple elle raconte une petite anecdote
où elle demande dans une salle pleine de
politique si ils aimeraient bien dans
coup de baguette magique faire
disparaître toute la dette publique et
répond tous mais oui ce serait génial et
du coup elle leur demande si dans le
même temps il serait aussi favorable
vous faire disparaître du même coup de
baguette magique toutes les obligations
d'État et là ils disent mais non vous
serez horrible on a besoin des bons du
Trésor pour avoir des actifs sûrs qui
stabilisent les marchés financiers et
visiblement il ne voit pas du tout la
dissonance cognitive du au fait que une
obligation d'État
c'est de la dette d'État c'est
littéralement la même chose mais qu'on
le regarde soit du point de vue du
débiteur soit du point de vue du
créancier mais on n'a pas l'un sans
l'autre voilà donc le livre présente une
bonne partie théorique ou l'autrice nous
réexplique le fonctionnement de la
création et de la politique monétaire
avec plein de métaphores et
d'illustrations qui rendent ça super
clair puis ensuite elle a toute une
partie où elle détaille à quel point le
fonctionnement actuel des institutions
est inefficace parce que tous les
dirigeants sont obsédés par le montant
de la dette publique même au sein du
parti démocrate qui devrait normalement
être plus ouvert à cette façon de voir
l'économie et elle pointe comment cette
peur du déficit monétaire produit de
vrais déficits grave aux États-Unis
comme le déficit de bonne emploi le
définitif de santé le déficit
d'éducation le déficit climatique ou le
déficit démocratique
ces dernières parties sont donc plus un
diagnostic circonstancié sur les
institutions spécifiquement américaines
mais franchement on n'a aucun mal à voir
en quoi la plupart des problèmes évoqués
pourrait s'appliquer tout aussi bien à
nos pays européens
voilà je peux pas vous en dire beaucoup
plus sinon vous conseiller de lire le
livre c'est vraiment une lecture
passionnante et en plus c'est écrit avec
beaucoup d'énergie de clarté et d'humour
donc je vois pas ce qui vous retient on
passe maintenant au livre suivant
numéro 4 au commencement était une
nouvelle histoire de l'humanité par
David Greber et David wengro paru aux
liens qui libère en 2022 et oui un
deuxième livre de David Graber dans
cette sélection qui lui du coup est paru
à titre posthume donc il ne pourra
jamais voir tout le succès qu'il a
rencontré et je vous avoue que j'en
pleure encore plus sa mort parce que
normalement ce tome aurait dû être le
premier d'une série de 3 et que a priori
les deux autres ne sortiront jamais
donc je vous ai déjà présenté David
Graber il coécrit ici avec l'archéologue
David wengro avec qui il a eu un échange
pendant de nombreuses années et ce livre
est le résultat de leur collaboration
pluridisciplinaire fructueuse dans
laquelle il propose tout simplement de
réactualiser l'histoire un peu trop
souvent réchauffée de toute l'humanité
rien que ça on intégrant toutes les
dernières recherches anthropologiques et
archéologiques rien que ça alors comme
vous pouvez le voir c'est un sacré pavé
il est massif et c'est peut-être son
seul défaut à mes yeux c'est que il nous
blast avec tellement d'informations et
de recherche diverses que c'est parfois
un petit peu difficile de s'y retrouver
c'est pour ça que initialement je
l'avais mis un petit peu plus bas dans
le classement mais le fait que seulement
quelques mois après l'avoir fini je
viens de le recommencer et je vous avoue
que c'est quand même assez rare que je
revienne aussi vite sur un livre comme
ça et à la relecture je me dois bien le
reconnaître que ce livre est vraiment
brillant et je précise aussi que ce que
j'aime en particulier c'est la première
partie du livre qui est particulièrement
stimulante et passionnante à mes yeux
mais qu'est-ce qui est si passionnant me
direz-vous et bien avant tout c'est un
énorme travail de déconstruction de
toutes les grandes synthèses qui ont
essayé de raconter l'histoire de
l'humanité comme celle de Francis
Fukuyama Jared Diamonds ou même Yovan
dont je vous ai parlé un petit peu plus
tôt le fait est que bien souvent on a
une façon beaucoup trop linéaire de nous
raconter l'histoire de l'humanité et ça
fait en gros ça avant on vivait comme
des petits groupes de chasseurs
cueilleurs et puis un jour il y a eu la
révolution agricole on a commencé à
construire des villes et inévitablement
le pouvoir s'est formalisé et
hiérarchisé parce que c'est inévitable
quand on doit coordonner des grands
groupes humains et globalement ce que
disent les deux Davids ici c'est que
cette façon de raconter l'histoire et
ben c'est de la merde en fait il se
battent surtout contre l'aspect
téléologique de ces récits ça veut dire
contre l'impression qu'il était
inévitable que nos sociétés évoluent
comme cela si on prend l'exemple des
hommes préhistoriques on passe souvent
très vite on nous racontant globalement
que c'était des petits chasseurs
cueilleurs et il vivait en petit comités
dans des groupes très égalitaires ok si
on veut mais là on est quand même en
train de parler de l'organisation
sociale des humains sur plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'années et sur
toute la surface du globe est-ce que
c'est vraiment réaliste de par défaut
que l'humanité a connu une seule forme
d'organisation sociale pendant toutes
ces années en fait ce que ça cache c'est
qu'on a souvent tendance à considérer
nos sociétés modernes comme avancer et
réflexive et du coup quand on pense aux
préhistorique on leur enlève un peu leur
capacité à penser des structures
sociales complexes ou simplement
différentes des nôtres en présupposant
qu'ils s'organisait plutôt par nécessité
est-ce que fait le livre c'est de
considérer les humains à toutes les
époques comme capable d'inventer des
formes de vie sociale particulière et
c'est assez bien étayé par les
découvertes archéologiques en fait il
semblerait même que c'est plutôt nous
qui actuellement sommes restés bloqué à
des sociétés hiérarchisées là où nos
ancêtres obéissaient à des modes
d'organisation opposés à la hiérarchie
et surtout beaucoup plus diverses
notamment en ce qui concerne
l'agriculture il montre par exemple
qu'elle n'a pas forcément marqué un
tournant incontournable vers la
sédentarité mais qui a eu plein de
cultures humaines qui l'ont adopté puis
abandonner puis redécouverte et on a
plein de va-et-vient comme ça de la la
même façon pour ce qui est de la
hiérarchie c'est pas du tout un fait
inéluctable encore au début du 20e
siècle les anthropologues ont pu
observer des sociétés aux formes
d'organisation saisonnières ou l'hiver
est marqué par une forme très
autoritaire de pouvoir centraliser et au
contraire l'été est marqué par un grand
degré de liberté proche de l'anarchie et
le pouvoir est lui-même tournant délégué
à une famille différente à chaque
nouvelle hiver bref l'idée c'est que les
formes d'organisation sociale sont
foisonnantes et virtuellement infinies
et qu'il faut qu'on arrête notre pensée
historiciste selon laquelle il y aurait
des modes de société incontournables et
surtout des points de passage obligé
pour y parvenir un autre point que je
trouve passionnant c'est qu'il faut
aussi la généalogie de la pensée
occidentale et de la façon qu'elle a eu
d'observer les autres populations par
exemple il montre que pendant longtemps
on est resté coincé entre deux visions
opposées et ultra réduits sur la façon
de penser l'humanité celle de Hobbs et
celle de Rousseau Hobbs considéré que
l'homme à l'état de nature était mauvais
et c'est la raison pour laquelle une
fois installé un état Léviathan pour
contraindre et empêcher ses pulsions
mortifères à l'inverse Rousseau avait
une vision de l'homme naturel comme doux
et empathique et voyez donc le contrat
social comme une soumission volontaire
au bien commun instaurer dans un premier
temps pour protéger la propriété privée
mais le problème c'est que c'est deux
visions sont aussi merdiques l'une que
l'autre et surtout elles ont eu pour
effet que pendant des années les
Occidentaux ont vu des populations
autochtones comme ces fameuses hommes
naturels non encore contaminé par la
modernité et c'est notamment ce qui est
à la racine de ce qu'on appelle le mythe
du bon sauvage c'est notamment à travers
ce mythe que de nombreux auteurs des
lumières comme Montaigne Diderot ont pu
faire passer des critiques sur leur
société actuelle en donnant la parole à
des personnages étrangers on a par
exemple un chef tahitien dans le
supplément en voyage de Bougainville de
Diderot et ce que j'ignorais avant de
lire ce livre c'est que c'est loin
d'être une métaphore en fait toutes les
idées qu'on attribue souvent aux
lumières elles viennent principalement
des penseurs américains et attention par
penseur américains je désigne bien les
philosophes indigènes de l'époque quand
on se repenche sur le carnet des
voyageurs jésuites ou des missionnaires
qui ont échangé avec les natifs
d'Amérique on s'aperçoit que ces
derniers étaient de grands philosophes
et des batteurs et que leur organisation
sociale démocratique et libertaire les
obliger à être tous capables d'écouter
les autres et de défendre des idées et
ce bien mieux que les Occidentaux de
fait si on lit les propos du chef
wendate Kandia Ronk originaire de
l'actuel Québec dans la deuxième moitié
du XVIIIe siècle on s'aperçoit que
beaucoup de ces préceptes sont ceux
qu'on a retrouvé plus tard sous la plume
de nos philosophes des Lumières et
d'ailleurs eux-mêmes n'en faisait pas
mystère beaucoup de ces philosophes à
l'époque disaient déjà que ils étaient
en train de recycler des idées des
penseurs natifs c'est juste que pendant
tant d'années on a tellement vu ces
natifs comme des animaux qu'en fait on
ne les croyait pas on se disait non non
mais en fait ils attribuent ces pensées
à des personnages natifs mais c'est pour
mieux faire passer leurs idées à eux
alors que non pour de vrai y récupérer
des idées défenseurs natifs bon il
serait impossible de résumer en quelques
minutes un livre aussi foisonnant qui
fourmille d'exemples et qui met en avant
des phénomènes sociaux variés pour
expliquer tel ou telle forme sociale
il détaille par exemple le phénomène de
la sismogénèse qui désigne le fait que
certaines sociétés se construisent en
opposition les unes aux autres en
s'efforçant d'adopter des traits
culturels opposés à leurs voisins ce qui
explique une partie de la diversité des
formes sociales l'idée c'est donc bien
ici de rompre avec la vision
évolutionniste de l'histoire en
s'opposant notamment à la théorie des
quatre stades cette idée selon laquelle
on serait passé de la bande à la tribu
puis à la chefferie puis à l'état non
c'est pas aussi simple bon et finalement
ceux qui en ressort c'est un sentiment
assez libérateur parce que le livre
montre d'une façon assez magistrale
qu'il n'y a pas une seule façon
d'organiser les sociétés humaines et
surtout il n'y a pas non plus une
meilleure façon de vivre en société même
si on pourrait imaginer qu'il y en
aurait peut-être des moins bonnes mais à
un moment où on perd tous un peu espoir
dans le changement social et où on
imagine qu'il serait en fait plus
possible d'inventer autre chose c'est
assez rafraîchissant de voir qu'on a en
fait une quasi infinité de modèles
sociaux dans lesquels on peut piocher du
coup si vous n'avez pas peur des gros
livres je vous conseille fortement la
lecture de au commencement été il est
aussi disponible en livre audio si
jamais ça peut vous aider à franchir le
pas c'est un livre magnifique écrit de
façon simple et claire et surtout qui
pousse à l'introspection et à réfléchir
sur nos propres préjugés et maintenant
laissons un regret David Greber et
commençons les roulements de tambour
parce qu'on entre dans le Top 3
numéro 3 pourquoi les top models ne
sourient pas chronique sociologique de
Baptiste coulemon et Pierre Berke paru
aux Presses des mines en 2020 alors là
on est sur quelque chose de beaucoup
plus léger mais qui reste
ultra cool à lire en termes de lecture
d'été je crois que je peux difficilement
vous conseiller mieux en fait comme son
sous-titre l’indique le livre est une
compilation de toutes les chroniques que
les deux sociologues ont écrites pour le
monde sous l'intitulé carte blanche
et du coup pourquoi les top models ne
sourient pas c'est juste le titre de
l'une des chroniques parmi d'autres et
d'ailleurs je ne vous dirai pas pourquoi
il faudra aller lire le livre pour avoir
la réponse comme je vous l'avais dit
pour le Cabinet de Curiosité sociale de
Browner j'adore le livre qui sont des
compilations d'articles comme celui-ci
et oui si vous ne saviez pas cet
apparemment un genre à part entière je
vous avais recommandé il y a quelques
années le livre de Paul kruckman lutter
contre les zombies ces idées qui
détruisent l'Amérique alors même si
c'est très décevant parce qu'il y a pas
de zombie dedans le livre est super cool
et c'est une compilation de toutes les
contributions qu'il avait fait pour le
Times et donc dans ma liste de lecture
pour cet été je me suis gardé vivement
le socialisme une compilation des
chroniques de Piketty pour le monde les
chroniques décalées dans l'économiste
qui regroupent les contributions
d'Emmanuel Combes dans l'opinion et les
chroniques critiques de l'économie qui
compilent les contributions de Jézabel
coupé Soubeyran Mathilde Dupré Florence
genicatrice Dominique Méda et Laurent
sialom pour France Culture donc autant
dire que j'aurais pas le temps de
m'ennuyer cet été bref si j'aime ce
genre de publication c'est notamment
parce que en général fluide et bien
écrit parce que ça s'adresse au plus
grand nombre et personnellement j'ai de
plus en plus de mal avec les livres qui
jargonne en plus ça permet d’aborder
plein de questions différentes avec un
angle souvent nouveau et intéressant
donc le livre de coolmont et merkley il
est organisé en 5 grandes parties
d'abord la partie épistémologique qui
s'appelle la science de la science dans
laquelle on retrouve des aspects plutôt
méthodologiques comme à quoi servent les
statistiques ou bien le fameux article
Astérix chez les économistes qui avaient
été ma source d'inspiration pour faire
ma vidéo sur l'arrogance des économistes
oui parce que une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'aime bien ce type de
publication c'est aussi parce que ça me
donne plein d'idées pour des angles
originaux à traiter en vidéo une autre
partie s'intéresse ensuite au monde du
travail avec des analyses sur les
pourboires ou sur les tutoiements en
entreprise la partie 3 traite de la
famille et de la sexualité la partie 4
du monde de la politique et la partie 5
des classes et des réseaux sociaux ou on
trouvera notamment l'article sur les top
models qui donnent son titre au recueil
chaque partie est composée du douzaine
de chroniques qui se font de une à trois
quatre chacune donc il y a plein
d'articles différents
ultra intéressant et j'ai d'ailleurs
plusieurs fois piocher des idées dans ce
livre puisque il y a tout un article sur
la croyance au Père Noël qui avait été
le point de départ de ma série vidéo sur
le Père Noël même si je tiens ici à
poser une petite gueulante contre une
erreur d'édition parce que regardez je
vais vous retrouver ça voilà regardez
les pages 92 et 93 sont parfaitement
identiques du coup il me manque la page
93 c'est quand même fâcheux je demande à
recevoir la page 93 bon du coup je pense
que vous avez compris c'est cool c'est
intéressant c'est bien écrit ça aborde
plein de questions différentes et
surtout c'est facilement accessible à
tous le livre avait été en sélection au
prix lycéen du livre de ses l'année
dernière il était arrivé à la troisième
place et bah comme dans mon top
d'ailleurs si vous ne connaissez pas le
prix lycéen du livre de ses je vous
conseille dit jeter un œil c'est comme
le prix Goncourt des lycéens mais pour
les livres de sciences sociales tous les
ans les lycéens lisent 8 livres en
compétition et vote pour leur préférée
mais on sera amené en reparlé du coup
encore une fois je vous recommande
chaudement les chroniques sociologiques
de clomon et Merley et maintenant on
passe au numéro 2
numéro 2 où va l'argent des pauvres de
Denis Colombie Paris en 2019 chez Payot
bon alors je sais j'arrive un peu après
la bataille parce que ça commence à
faire un moment qu'il est sorti mais moi
je ne les rattraper que l'année dernière
et je comprends enfin tout le fuzz qu'on
a fait au tour de ce livre alors Denis
Colombie si vous ne le connaissez pas
déjà shame on you et puis pour les
autres bah il est professeur de sciences
économiques et sociales au lycée mais
c'est surtout l'un des premiers à avoir
fait de la vulgarisation de sociologie
sur Internet à travers son blog une
heure de peine pour ceux qui n'ont pas
la raie fin le blog s'appelle une heure
de Pen en raison d'une phrase ultra
célèbre de Durkheim dans la préface de
la division du travail social dans
laquelle il nous dit nous estimerions
que nos recherches ne méritent pas une
heure de peine si elle ne devait avoir
qu'un intérêt spéculatif
l'idée c'est que bien sûr comme toute
science la sociologie doit servir avant
tout à faire agrandir le stock de
connaissances mais il faut aussi qu'elle
servent à quelque chose notamment sur le
plan politique pour Durkheim le
sociologue doit aider à comprendre les
problèmes de la société ont vu
d'éventuellement les résoudre mais du
coup la première étape de ce processus
c'est avant toute chose de rendre
accessible le savoir sociologique et
c'est précisément ce que se propose de
faire Denis Colombie dans ce livre et
avec son blog évidemment il fait donc
une compilation minutieuse et argumentée
de la littérature qui existe sur la
pauvreté et il nous présente donc les
résultats de tous les travaux qui
traitent de cette question et il entend
bien battre en brèche un certain nombre
d'idées reçues sur le sujet donc ici on
n'a pas un ouvrage d'enquête il y a pas
de terrain spécifiquement c'est surtout
un ouvrage de vulgarisation qui vise à
rendre accessible toute une somme de
travaux réalisés sur le sujet de la
pauvreté alors dès le début il remet les
points sur les i en montrant qu'il y a
énormément de préjugés négatifs sur de
la façon qu'aurait les pauvres de gérer
leur argent et que plein de gens
essayent d'apporter des solutions alors
qu'ils y connaissent rien et qui du coup
ils comprennent même pas bien quel est
le problème dans le genre de grosse
dinguerie qu'on a pu voir sur le sujet
on se rappelle bien sûr de Jean-Michel
blancaire qui affirmait son trembler des
genoux que la prime de rentrée scolaire
était parfois utilisée pour acheter des
écrans plats et quand tout le monde lui
a demandé mais d'où il tirait cette
information parce que il y a vraiment
aucune étude qui laisse paraître un
résultat pareil et que septembre c'est
précisément le deuxième mois de l'année
où il y a le moins de ventes de
téléviseurs en France juste après le
mois d'août entre parenthèses et bien ce
bon vieux Beluga se contenté de nous
répondre parce qu'il y a une grosse
si on regarde des choses en face que
parfois il y a des achats d'écran plat
plus important au mois de septembre qui
a d'autres moments donc bien sûr que ce
qui peut y avoir qu'on peut regarder ça
alors cette façon là donc des bons
d'achat ça peut être intéressant mais à
ce on sait bien je crois que c'est le
pire ennemi de la sociologie et quand on
lui pointe les résultats des études il
nous répond que encore une fois sur ce
sujet vous savez cette phrase
c'est des enquêtes sur des déclarations
de ce que disent les gens donc si vous
voulez soyons essayons d'être sérieux
sur ces sujets c'est-à-dire de et ben
super c'est gentil pour les dizaines de
chercheurs qui travaillent justement sur
ces questions avec des matériaux ultra
divers ce petit exemple ça nous permet
de voir plusieurs choses c'est que sur
ces sujets là déjà on porte toujours en
jugement négatif sur la façon dont les
pauvres dépensent leur argent d'où
toutes les techniques pour essayer de
cibler les achats avec des chèques non
convertibles par exemple parce qu'a
toujours ce soupçon d'irresponsabilité
sur leur donner directement de l'argent
et en plus l'opinion publique est en
particulier le monde politique baigne
dans cette espèce d'auto-persuasion avec
des arguments du type non mais on sait
bien que ça se passe comme ça on se
reposant uniquement sur des préjugés et
en allant jamais voir les travaux de
sciences sociales à titre d'exemple
cette affirmation sans fondement sur les
téléviseurs et la prime de rentrée
scolaire elle en fait était lancée par
l'UMP en 2008 d'absolument nulle part et
depuis elle traîne comme ça dans les
consciences alors qu'elle a jamais été
basée que sur du vent bref c'est juste
un exemple mais ça vous montre qu'on
part de loin sur ces questions-là et à
quel point il faut déconstruire nos
préjugés pour réfléchir un minimum de
façon sérieuse pour étudier ça Colombie
commence donc par analyser tous les
jugements de valeur qu'on porte à propos
des questions de l'argent et de la
pauvreté en regardant commençons souvent
représentés les bons pauvres et les
mauvais pauvres et surtout la
distinction faite entre le bon argent
qui serait mérité et le mauvais argent
qui serait indu on est un pognon de
dingue on des responsabilise on est dans
le curatif et patrons
[Musique]
déjà il montre que en général tout le
monde est biaisé sur cette question et
que les débats sur l'argent et sur la
pauvreté ils servent en général moins un
but de connaissances qu'il ne remplisse
une fonction
identitaire et surtout de positionnement
politique on est contre l'argent et du
côté des pauvres si on est de gauche et
on est pour l'argent et contre la
victimisation des pauvres si on est de
droite du coup Colombie nous invite à
nous défaire de tous ces préjugés et
d'éviter les deux écueils que serait le
populisme et le misérabilisme
c'est-à-dire d'un côté considéré que les
pauvres sont authentiques autonome et
bon par nature et de l'autre côté le
problème serait de ne pas les considérer
comme des personnes à part entière parce
qu'ils vivraient leur vie uniquement
sous le prisme de la privation du coup
il faut regarder les pauvres pour de
vrai pas les considérer comme des démons
mais pas les considérer comme des anges
non plus regardés en face qu'on peut
effectivement trouver du racisme de la
misogynie ou de l'usage de drogue mais
que c'est fait doivent être avant tout
compris et expliquer notamment dans le
rapport qu'ils entretiennent avec la
pauvreté mais surtout et c'est un des
passages qui m’a le plus intéressé le
premier chapitre s'intéresse à tous les
jugements moraux comportent sur l'argent
lui-même et qui affecte notre façon de
réfléchir à cette question vous savez
c'est cette idée que l'argent corrompt
et qu'il est un objet sale nature c'est
quelque chose qu'on retrouve aussi dans
les contes et dans les fictions et c'est
évidemment quelque chose qu'on retrouve
dans les récits religieux on se rappelle
ce que racontait Max Weber dans
l'éthique protestante et l'esprit du
capitalisme et il partait du paradoxe
qu'il est étonnant que le capitalisme se
soit développé dans des pays chrétiens
parce que selon la Bible il est plus
facile à un chameau de passer par le
trou d'une aiguille qui a un riche de
rentrer dans le royaume de Dieu
autrement dit l'argent c'est mal et il
vaut mieux rester pauvre parce que c'est
eux qui arriveront premier au paradis et
même si on est pas religieux on trouve
cette même condamnation de l'argent chez
Marx par exemple qui critique le
fétichisme de la marchandise et c'est
évidemment quelque chose qui va
influencer les jugements sur les aides
sociales et qui font préférer à beaucoup
de gens d'apporter des aides en nature
plutôt qu'en monnaie parce que les
pauvres se laisseraient trop facilement
contaminer par l'impureté de l'argent
Colombie illustre ça avec l'anecdote du
philosophe autrichien ludwigenstein bien
connu des gros cerveaux pour son tractus
Logico philosophicus ce a reçu un gros
héritage de son père mais il a décidé de
s'en débarrasser paraît-il parce qu'il
voulait pas être aimé pour son argent et
du coup il décide de le donner à ses
sœurs qui étaient pourtant déjà pété de
thunes à plus savoir quoi en on
pourrait se demander pourquoi pourquoi
ne pas l'avoir donné au plus pauvre et
son raisonnement est apparemment limpide
puisque l'argent coron donnons-le à des
corrompus cette anecdote elle sert
généralement à illustrer l’excentricité
de VTT Einstein ou même les conséquences
d'un excès de logique sur l'esprit et si
on peut effectivement s'en moquer le
point de Colombie c'est de se demander
est-ce qu'on est si différent de
vilgenstein quand il s'agit de l'argent
ou de la pauvreté le fait est que quand
on regarde il semble que l'après-midi
selon laquelle l'argent coron et quand
même pas mal répondu dans les jugements
moraux ordinaires sur la question bref
je trouve ce travail de déconstruction
particulièrement passionnant et dans la
suite du livre il va restituer la façon
d'arbitrer des plus pauvres en se basant
sur des travaux
la cause de certains comportements de
dépenses qui parfois certes sont des
choix discutables parce que quand on
regarde la réalité évidemment il y en a
qui craquent et qui dépense tout par
exemple la Française des jeux mais on
voit que bien souvent les pauvres gèrent
leur argent avec beaucoup plus
d'habilité qu'on ne leur fait crédit et
c'est d'autant plus impressionnant que
justement c'est une activité à plein
temps qui demande des ressources
mentales considérables notamment pour
être tenu sur le long terme arbitrer un
budget serré c'est particulièrement
difficile et les pauvres sont sortent
finalement pas si mal pour finir ce
livre de Colombie est un livre important
que tout le monde sans exception devrait
lire et en particulier il devrait être
obligatoire pour n'importe quelle
politique qui aurait l'outrecuidance
d'ouvrir son clapet sur ces questions là
d'ailleurs le public ne sait pas trompé
parce que le livre a gagné la première
place au prix lycéen du livre de ses
pour l'année 2020 et il le mérite très
largement ça fait depuis le premier
confinement que ce livre est sur ma pile
de lecture et je regrette d'avoir mis
autant de temps à l'attaquer entre temps
de nicolombie a eu le temps d'en écrire
un autre pourquoi sommes-nous
capitalistes malgré nous dans la
fabrique de l'homo économicus toujours
chez Payot et je vais de ce pas
l'ajouter à ma pile de lecture pour
cette année donc évidemment vous aurez
compris je vous conseille très fortement
la lecture de où va l'argent des pauvres
mais surtout je vous conseille de suivre
Denis Colombie sur Twitter il est très
drôle et très actif il raconte plein de
trucs intéressants au milieu de tweet
sur Zelda et sur Batman d'ailleurs Denis
si un jour ça t'intéresse qu'on fasse un
épisode en collab sur Batman je suis
méga show et je me verrai difficilement
aborder le sujet sur ton expertise voilà
le message est passé mais maintenant que
tout ça est dit même si vous avez
compris à quel point j'ai aimé la
lecture de ce livre il nous reste la
lecture que j'ai préféré de l'année 2022
numéro 1 les nouvelles lois de l'amour
sexualité couple et rencontre au temps
du numérique de Marie berkstrom publié à
la découverte en 2019 alors encore une
fois c'est complètement subjectif mais
c'est le livre que j'ai le plus apprécié
l'année dernière c'est un sujet
ultra intéressant c'est clair c'est bien
écrit et surtout ça utilise un matériau
d'enquête original et ultra divers qui
en fait un livre mille fois plus solide
que la plupart de ce qui paraît sur le
sujet bon je commence par une petite
digression mais une des raisons pour
lesquelles je trouve ce livre aussi bien
c'est parce qu'il est vraiment basé et
qu'on est sur un sujet sur lequel il y a
beaucoup de non spécialistes qui
s'expriment par exemple on a le cas de
zigmoon Bowman qui est souvent présenté
comme un sociologue mais qui est selon
moi est plutôt un philosophe spécialisé
dans l'analyse de la postmodernité son
grand concept c'est celui de la
liquidité des liens sociaux qu'il a
trouvé dans son livre de 2003 l'amour
liquide de la fragilité des liens entre
les hommes dans lequel il montre que
globalement aujourd'hui les gens ont de
plus en plus peur de s'engager et du
coup ça crée des formes d'insécurité
parce que les liens sont beaucoup plus
fragiles liquides et alors il va
l'adorer sa métaphore de la liquidité
parce que après l'amour liquide on va
avoir droit à la vie liquide et puis au
présent liquide bref tout est liquide et
évidemment même si je caricature de ouf
je sais bien on est quand même pas très
loin du jugement de valeur visant à
montrer que l'amour aujourd'hui c'est
plus que c'était on s'appuyant en
général sur un matériau empirique assez
faible voire inexistant et en parallèle
de ce genre d'écrit catastrophiste on a
aussi des gens qui s'intéressent à ce
sujet alors qu'il n'y connaissent rien
bon là je vous préviens je vais bitcher
un peu mais bon si vous êtes resté
jusqu'ici c'est que ça doit pas trop
vous déranger de m'entendre déblatérer
et du coup je profite de faire un format
de vidéo un peu plus détente pour
aborder un truc qui m'a fait rager il y
a presque trois ans donc j'étais en
train de regarder l'émission quotidien
du 4 septembre 2020 et il reçoivent
l'économiste libérale Nicolas pour
parler d'amour parce que figurez-vous
qu'il vient de publier l'amour augmenté
nos enfants et nos amours au 21e siècle
aux éditions l'Observatoire alors je
vous préviens je l'ai pas lu mais rien
que son intervention a suffi à me garder
à tout jamais de le faire déjà un peu de
contexte il n'est pas rare que des
économistes s'intéressent à des sujets
qui sont traditionnellement traités par
des sociologues on a appelé ça
l'impérialisme économique et l'idée
c'est que comme l'économie se définit
elle-même comme la science du choix les
économistes se sentent en général
légitimes à aborder tous les aspects de
la vie humaine le spécialiste en la
matière c'est l'économiste Gary Baker
qui a étudié la déviance le mariage ou
la culture en général ça donne des
travaux quand même assez pauvres parce
qu'ils étudient tout sous le prisme de
l'acteur rationnel ils se font rarement
chier à lire les autres travaux qui
existent déjà sur le sujet du coup quand
je vois un économiste débarquait sur un
sujet comme ça je suis déjà un petit peu
sceptique et on voit le problème dès le
début de l'émission quand il commence à
parler du polyamour et qui leur donne
une définition je ne sais pas mais le
polyamour
pardonnez-moi cette propre du point de
vue français mais on peut être en couple
à trois ou quatre non pas seulement à
deux mais au fond j'aime une personne
mais je peux aussi aimer deux ou trois
personnes et donc on va faire personne
déjà sa définition est aux fraises et ne
correspond pas du tout au consensus pour
ceux qui étudient cette question et puis
surtout il suppose direct que c'est
impossible
pas possible ça existe pas et son
argumentation est claqué au sol
heureusement que myamazoret est sur le
plateau pour lui offrir un petit peu de
répondant cette expérience auprès de vos
convois dites-lui écoute j'ai une idée
super je ne vais pas avoir uniquement
toi comme conjoint mais je vais en avoir
trop ouatre est-ce que tu es d'accord
avec eux
c'est tout est basé sur l'honnêteté
mais ça c'est génial alors le concept
est super mais simplement ça n'existe
pas dans la réalité
et là son gros argument pour dire que ça
marche pas mais c'est que ça ferait beau
voir on essayait et qu'avec eux ça
marchait pas l'idée c'est que c'est
surtout Sartre qui en profiter mais que
Simone a probablement été très
malheureuse et du coup bah c'est tout on
en reste là il y a pas d'autres argument
pas d'études plus récente et à nouveau
merci Maya heureusement qu'elle est là
pour remettre un petit peu les points
sur les i c'est plutôt l'infidélité
qui est la personne qui a théorisé le
polyamour en France en 1967 de mémoire
a fait pas mal d'adaptes en fait il y a
tout un espèce d'outillage intellectuel
qui s'est formé auprès des couples et
des quadruples polyamoureux pour faire
en sorte justement que ça se passe bien
et qu'on puisse échanger avec beaucoup
d'honnêteté beaucoup de transparence
sans se faire du mal en étant d'accord
en faisant des enfants et en partant en
vacances
au sujet d'études il arrive même pas à
en croire la meuf mille fois plus basée
qu'il est en face de lui oui si si bien
sûr le mec aborde un sujet auquel il
nous connaît rien on ayant lu aucun
papier et en ne prenant que des analyses
individuelles pour lequel il prend
visiblement sa propre existence pour
juger tout le reste de l'humanité non
j'ai pas essayé mais deuxième mais mon
conjoint est pas d'accord puis je serai
pas d'accord qui me propose lequel me
propose dans l'occurrence le polyamour
et ça ça se fait inviter sur des
plateaux télé d'ailleurs il se fait
toujours autant inviter dans les médias
même après que les uber files ont révélé
qu'il a touché près de 10000 euros de
l'entreprise uber pour mener une étude
qui bizarrement à trouver que c'était
vachement bien que uber aille
s'installer en France et que ça allait
créer plein d'emplois
mais bon je digresse graisse mais je
pense que le passage qui m'a le plus
c'est rager de toutes les missions c'est
celui-là quand on parle des effets des
nouvelles technologies sur l'amour mais
aujourd'hui si j'avais 20 ans
j'utiliserai les applis parce que
fantasme toujours le passé alors vous
savez ça c'est les sociologues ils
disent les applis c'est horrible c'est
la marchandisation de l'amour mais alors
le bal musette c'était quand même
beaucoup mieux et puis les chevaliers
qui allaient délivrer les princesses
alors ça c'était mais pardon mais de
quelle sociologue tu parles en fait
quelle sociologue fait des jugements de
valeur ce sont des objets d'études c'est
juste pas une bonne méthode d'enquête
cette dévaluation du travail de gens que
visiblement il ne lit même pas ça le don
de m'énerver alors on cherche en bien il
fait peut-être référence au travail
d'éveil loose dans son livre pourquoi
l'amour fait mal qui date de 2012 et
dans lequel elle traite effectivement
des aspects négatifs qu'on peut imputer
à une certaine marchandisation de
l'amour mais elle le fait sur un
échantillon assez petit il faudrait que
je revienne plus longuement dessus pour
en parler plus en détail mais surtout au
moment de l'émission ça fait déjà un an
que le livre de Marie berkstraum était
sorti et s'il avait lu ça lui aurait
sûrement permis de dire beaucoup moins
de conneries
bon c'est bon j'ai fini passons au livre
du coup venons-en au livre de Marie
berktrum justement qu'est-ce qui en fait
un travail aussi intéressant alors déjà
je vous la présente rapidement Marie
berkstrom elle est sociologue à l'Inde
spécialiste du couple du genre et les
applications de rencontre et en fait ce
livre il est issu de sa thèse de
doctorat qu'elle a commencé en 2014 et
qui porte précisément sur la sexualité
les classes sociales et les rapports de
genre dans l'usage décide de rencontre
donc quand elle sort ce livre ça fait
déjà 5 ans qu'elle bosse sur ce sujet-là
et l'un des points intéressants c'est
qu'elle a pu faire au cours de sa thèse
un partenariat avec le site mythique qui
lui permet d'avoir accès à des milliers
de données utilisateurs anonymisés
évidemment et en parallèle elle a fait
aussi des dizaines d'entretiens
biographiques donc elle mêle à la fois
des données quantitatives avec des
analyses statistiques solides et donner
qualitatives qui lui permettent de mieux
saisir certains enjeux plus subjectifs
et d'ailleurs si tout ça c'est des
sujets qui vous intéressent et bien
c'est pas la première fois que je parle
de son travail sur Youtube parce que en
septembre dernier j'ai fait une vidéo
pour la chaîne Avid de recherche qui
porte sur la compréhension de la
différence d'âge entre les hommes et les
femmes sur les applications de rencontre
et c'était tiré des articles qu'elle
avait écrit pour la revue française de
sociologie elle étudie la différence
d'âge grâce à un gros traitement
statistique sur les données de mythique
et ça lui permet de débloquer un peu
certaines croyances qu'on pouvait avoir
sur le sujet on montrant qu'entre ce que
les gens disent qu'ils font sur les
appuis de rencontre et ce qu'ils le font
réellement il y a une différence non
négligeable mais je vous laisse aller
visionner la vidéo si vous voulez en
savoir plus alors son étude elle l'a
fait en fait sur deux versions
principaux bien sûr elle s'intéresse aux
usages individuels et à la façon dont
les acteurs sociaux s'approprient et
utilisent des sites de rencontres mais
elle a aussi tout en versant où elle
étudie les concepteurs de sites de
rencontres c'est à dire les entreprises
qui forment le marché plus ou moins
concurrentiels des sites de rencontres
dans lesquelles prennent place ces
interactions et comme elle le dit
elle-même c'est un secteur économique et
florissant qui croit et il me semble à
important de savoir avant de comprendre
ce que les gens en font mais qu'est-ce
qu'ils peuvent faire ou non et comment
est-ce que ces plateformes cadrent
finalement les donc finalement
comprendre ce nouveau secteur économique
qui sont les gens qui font ces
plateformes quels sont leurs normes
professionnelles quelles sont leurs
représentation de la rencontre et
comment est-ce que tout ça finalement ça
participe à un cadrer les
usages vous savez le travail que
justement géraldbronner n'a pas fait du
tout dans Apocalypse cognitive quand il
se propose d'étudier les comportements
en ligne l'intérêt de cette analyse
c'est que ça permet de remettre dans
leur contexte un certain nombre de
choses par exemple le tout premier site
de rencontre de l'histoire c'est le site
Match.com qui apparaît aux États-Unis en
1995 et c'est en fait initialement juste
la version numérique des petites
annonces qu'on pouvait trouver dans les
journaux et qui existent depuis des
décennies un peu partout dans le monde
c'est d'ailleurs un prisme par lequel
les sciences sociales c'était déjà
penchés sur la question comme le montre
ses articles de 1984 de François de
cinglé dans la rue française de
sociologie dans lequel il analysait les
manœuvres de séduction à travers les
annonces matrimoniales trouvées dans les
journaux
mais bien sûr les sites de rencontres se
sont complexifiés on est passé des
petites annonces au site avec chat
intégré puis aux applications
géolocalisées mais ces différentes
innovations ce sont développées un peu
comme n'importe quel marché initialement
concurrentiel avec des techniques de
mimétisme et de différenciation minimes
et c'est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles il y a autant de similitudes
entre tous les sites de rencontres ce
n'est pas forcément que c'est la
meilleure version objective qui a été
sélectionnée par le marché c'est que
tout le monde a copié à partir de la
même base ce qui fait que les premiers
acteurs notamment les sites de petites
annonces ont eu un impact considérable
sur le développement du marché dans son
ensemble qui comme elle le montre très
bien repose assez largement sur des
archétypes
ultra stéréotypées d'ailleurs s'il
existe aujourd'hui probablement des
milliers de sites de rencontres il se
trouve qu'ils appartiennent en réalité à
quelques grandes compagnies mères qui se
partagent le marché un peu comme sur
n'importe quel marché qui aurait des
tendances oligopolistiques à la
concentration verticale quand le marché
des voitures
par exemple le groupe américain match ne
possède pas que son site originel mais
il est aussi le propriétaire de tinder
de Meetic de okCupid ou de Planty of
fish pour ne donner que quelques
exemples donc on a l'impression que
c'est sites se font concurrence mais en
fait ils appartiennent à la même maison
mère une autre conséquence de ça c'est
qu'on observe du coup une segmentation
très forte du marché de la rencontre en
gros on a les énormes mastodontes
historiques comme tinder ou qui est
cupide qui récupère la majorité des
utilisateurs ce qui fait que les autres
applications si elles veulent exister
elles sont obligées de se spécialiser et
de se trouver des marchés de niche c'est
comme ça qu'on a vu des applis se
spécialiser dans les rencontres
extra-conjugales ou se spécialiser en
fonction de la ville de l'âge de
l'origine ethnique de la confession
religieuse ou même du milieu social avec
des applis réservés à l'élite bref on a
de la différenciation à tous les étages
et c'est là que les commentateurs mal
avisés analysent cette prolifération
comme un phénomène de société et comme
le signe qui aurait de moins en moins de
cohésion sociale à cause de la montée
des communautarismes mais il faut bien
voir que le fait qu'il y a des
applications spéciales pour maghrébin ou
spécial pour chrétiens pratiquants c'est
pas du tout à cause d'une montée du
communitarisme c'est à cause du
capitalisme c'est la simple recherche de
profit qui incite les entrepreneurs à
rechercher toujours de nouvelles niches
qui n'auraient pas encore été exploitées
pour espérer obtenir une part du gâteau
qui est le marché de la rencontre en
ligne c'est juste un petit exemple mais
pour vous montrer en quoi observer juste
les usages sans tenir compte des
structures dans lesquelles se déroulent
ces usages mais ça peut nous rendre
aveugle à une bonne partie de
l'explication la plus pertinente après
je vais pas tout vous raconter dans le
détail je vous invite évidemment à lire
le livre ou au moins aller écouter ma
réaction en conférence je vous mettrai
des liens dans la description l'intérêt
du livre c'est notamment de montrer que
si internet change effectivement les
usages on est loin de la Révolution
catastrophique qui a été annoncée par
les plus pessimistes Marie berkram
répond aussi aux hypothèses qui ont été
formulées sur le fait que les
applications de rencontre pourraient
favoriser une plus grande hétérogénéité
sociale des couples en permettant la
rencontre de personnes qui ne se
seraient pas croisé habituellement pour
le coup c'est un terrain d'études assez
classique en sciences sociales depuis
les travaux d'Alain Girard en 1964 on a
mis en avant le phénomène d'homogamie
sociale c'est à dire le fait qu'on a
souvent tendance à se mettre en couple
avec des gens du même milieu social et
c'est quelque chose qui a été étudié
dans une célèbre enquête portant sur le
choix du conjoint fait en 1988 par
François Iran et Michel boson Michel
Bozon qui était d'ailleurs le directeur
de thèse de Marie berktrum blouson et
errant montrer notamment que les
personnes ne se rencontraient pas au
hasard et surtout qu'elles ne se
rencontrer pas au même endroit en
fonction de leur milieu social alors que
les classes populaires seront contre
davantage dans les lieux publics les
classes dominantes seront rencontrées
plus dans les lieux privés ou réservés
comme chez les amis par exemple mais
pour ce qui est des sites de rencontres
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a pas de grandes
révolution et même dans cet espace
privatisé les barrières entre les
groupes sociaux se recraient par exemple
on peut voir que sur Meetic le nombre de
mots utilisés est parfaitement corrélé
au niveau de diplôme des individus qui
est lui inv en corrélés à l'usage d'une
photographie il semble donc que même si
les usages sont cadrés et calibrés par
des plateformes tous les milieux sociaux
ne les investissent pas de la même façon
et elle met aussi en évidence des
stratégies plus ou moins actives qui
peuvent jouer de le rôle de filtre comme
certains de ces enquêtés qui affirment
couper la communication si jamais
l'interlocuteur fait trop de fautes
d'orthographe on voit bien comment un
filtre sur l'orthographe peut en réalité
un train filtre sur l'origine sociale et
du coup favoriser l'omogamie des
rencontres en ligne parmi les choses
vraiment nouvelles elle insiste sur le
fait qu'Internet permet une réelle
privatisation de la rencontre là où
auparavant elle se faisait davantage
sous le regard des autres dans un bar où
à l'école par exemple elle montre
notamment que cette privatisation elle
change particulièrement les usages pour
la jeune génération l'une des choses
qu'on remarque démographiquement c'est
que aujourd'hui on fait tout plus tard
on se met en couple plus tard on se
marie plus tard on fait des enfants plus
tard ce qui fait que le moment de la
jeunesse s'appréhende beaucoup plus
comme un moment d'expérimentation
relationnelle et sex essaie dans ce
moment d'expérimentation liée à la
jeunesse que les sites de rencontres
jouent un rôle très important parce
qu'il permet une certaine émancipation
de fait la jeunesse c'est un moment où
la sexualité est importante et on a tous
envie d'essayer des choses mais c'est
aussi un moment où on est contraint par
des univers normatifs que ce soit les
parents les camarades les amis il y a
des enjeux de réputation qui font qu'il
peut être difficile de faire tout ce
qu'on veut à ce titre les sites de
rencontres permettent de segmenter les
espaces entre se faire familiale faire
amicale et se faire des rencontres on
contre qui peuvent aller du simple plan
cul jusqu'à la rencontre de l'âme sœur
ça il y a tout le spectre qui
représentait de l'autre côté du spectre
des âges les applications sont aussi
beaucoup utilisées par les 40
cinquantenaires qui se remettent
généralement sur le marché matrimonial
après un divorce plus que la
privatisation de la rencontre l'intérêt
des plateformes ici c'est plutôt de
lutter contre une difficulté
démographique qui fait qu’après 30 ans
ben il y a beaucoup moins de personnes
disponibles et que ça peut être
difficile de rencontrer des gens qu'on
ne participe plus à les autres
sociabilité quotidien comme c'est le cas
quand on fait des études par exemple et
en plus il y a toujours l'inconfort
qu'on peut rencontrer à draguer en
soirée ou sur le lieu de travail on est
forcément soumis au regard des autres là
où les plateformes offrent le grand
avantage de clarifier d'emblée le but
recherché tout le monde sait au moins
implicitement pourquoi on est là et en
plus ça se fait son public mais il faut
bien noter que si on voit l'émergence de
ces nouveaux usages on observe pas
spécialement de changement dans les
normes globales de la société au
contraire l'obligation sociale à être en
couple elle est toujours aussi forte et
le couple amoureux est toujours une
norme ultra structurante par exemple 50%
des personnes divorcées se remettent en
couple dans les deux ans
bref encore une fois je vous renvoie
vers le livre il est extrêmement solide
sur le plan méthodologique passionnant
dans le nombre d'approches et de sujets
qu'il aborde et surtout il agit comme un
véritable antidote contre tous les
discours catastrophistes qui ne
regardent qu'un côté de la leur niette
et qui porte un jugement biaisé et
souvent plein de préjugés sur ces sujets
c'est fini et ben dis donc finalement
c'était plus long que ce que je pensais
ce top 10 de mes lectures 2022 est
maintenant terminée j'espère qu'il vous
aura plu mettez moi dans les
commentaires les livres que vous avez
préféré l'année dernière parmi ceux que
vous avez lu ou ceux qui vous donnent le
plus envie parmi ceux que j'ai abordé
aujourd'hui vous pouvez évidemment me
suivre sur les réseaux comme Facebook ou
Twitter et si jamais vous cherchez
toujours le livre parfait pour cet été
je vous rappelle que comprendre le monde
avec la pop culture et toujours
disponible et qu'ils sont portes très
bien à la plage non vraiment il est
vraiment très
plage compatible
mais surtout je suis assez impatient
d'avoir vos retours sur ce type de vidéo
initialement je vais juste prévu de
faire un petit top 10 à la fin de
l'année on vous parlant 30 secondes de
chaque livre et puis de faire une petite
vidéo de 10 minutes finalement j'ai
enregistré une première version de la
vidéo non scriptée j'ai trouvé ça
absolument horrible il y avait que des e
de partout et je ne disais rien
intéressant bref c'était le genre de
truc que j'aurais pas aimé regarder
moi-même donc j'ai tout supprimer et
j'ai préparé un script et du coup
forcément en essayant de dire une petite
chose intéressante sur chaque livre ben
ça prend vite des proportions de plus en
plus grandes et on arrive à des vidéos
d'une heure et demie mais bon de toute
façon ça a toujours été ma seule ligne
éditoriale sur la chaîne je fais des
vidéos qui me plaisent et que j'aurais
aimé voir en tant que public du coup moi
j'aime bien les vidéos très longues qui
abordent plein de sujets mais je suis
quand même curieux de savoir ce que vous
en avez pensé est-ce que ça vous a plu
est-ce que ça vous ferait plaisir que je
fasse un petit peu tous les sens en
revenant chaque fin d'année sur mes
lectures de l'année est-ce que
finalement c'était un peu chiant est-ce
que un top 10 c'est la fin de l'année ça
fonctionne ou est-ce que ce serait mieux
d'en faire peut-être
un peu moins mais plusieurs petites
vidéos par exemple faire deux trois fois
dans l'année des vidéos avec trois
quatre livres à chaque fois je sais pas
je vous laisse me donner vos idées en
tout cas moi je vous retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles choses je vous fais
des bisous avec votre consentement
évidemment Ciao
[Musique]